AND BRING OF THIS MORNING'S
JOINT INFORMATIONAL.
A HEARING TO START.
THANK YOU ALL FOR.
BEING HERE IN ATTENDING THIS
MORNING'S HEARING.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
THE TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUNDS
BEEN INCLUDED EIGHTEEN TRIBAL
STATE GAMING COMPACTS EXECUTED
BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
AS A MEANS TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF REVENUE SHARE BETWEEN
THE SEVENTY PLUS TRIBES WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR REVENUE SHARING
TRUST FUND ALLOCATIONS.
THE TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND IS
DEFINED WITH THOSE COMPACTS IS A
FUN TO MAKE DISCRETIONARY
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS TO NON
GAMING TRIBES AND LIMITED GAMING
TRIBES.
FOR PURPOSES RELATED TO
EFFECTIVE SELF GOVERNANCE SELF
DETERMINED COMMUNITY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
THE VARIOUS SPECIFICS OF HOW
THE.
TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUNDED
OPERATE.
WAS NOT DETAILED IN PRIOR
COMPAQ'S SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
TRIBES COULD PARTICIPATE IN A
BROADER DISCUSSION.
TRIBAL PARTICIPATION IS TAKING
PLACE THE REFORM DISCUSSIONS
INFORMAL CONSULTATIONS HELD
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND CALIFORNIA'S ARE STF
ELIGIBLE TRIBES.
THE CALIFORNIA GIMMICK CONTROL
COMMISSION ESTIMATES.
THIS YEAR FOR THE FIRST TIME
THERE WILL BE A SURPLUS OF
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUE SHARING TRUST
FUND.
THIS SURPLUS AND FUTURE FUNDS
COULD BE USED FOR BY THE ANNUAL
FUNDING FOR THE TRIBAL NATION
GRAPHITE.
POWER BEFORE ANY APPROPRIATION
BY THE LEGISLATURE CAN OCCUR.
ENABLING LEGISLATION WOULD NEED
TO BE ADOPTED TO PROVIDE
GUIDELINES FOR THE OPERATION AND
EXECUTION OF THE FUND.
FOLLOWING THE FORMAL
CONSULTATIONS WITH TRIBAL
LEADERS IN AFTER COMMENT PERIOD
LANGUAGES DRAFTED THAT
INCORPORATE THE IDEAS CONCERNS
SUGGESTIONS AND FINDINGS.
LAST SEPTEMBER THE LANGUAGES
AMENDED INTO A BILL. THAT I HAD
ON THE TNG AFTER IN THE SENATE.
I THEN HAD AB EIGHT EIGHTY
PLACED ON THE SENATE NOT TO FILE
TO GIVE THE RESPECTIVE
STAKEHOLDERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE FURTHER INPUT.
ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC.
THE GOAL OF TODAY'S HEARING IS
TO INFORM MEMBERS ABOUT THE
HISTORY AND THE OBJECTIVES OF
THE TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND.
I UNDERSTAND THE IMPLEMENTATION
FRAMEWORK ESTABLISHED BY THE
PROPOSED LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE
AND SEEK INPUT FROM ALL
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS ON
POTENTIAL REFINEMENTS OR
IMPROVEMENTS TO THAT FRAMEWORK.
WITH THAT.
I WILL. GIVE IT THE SENATE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT WHEN THE.
ARRIVED THEY'VE JUST ADJOURNED
OF SO WILL BE BEING JOINED BY. A
CHAIRMAN DODD.
MOMENTARILY AND WE WILL MOVE TO
ITEM TWO ON THE PUBLIC AGENDA.
AND ASKING NEED ONLY OUR
PRINCIPAL FISCAL POLICY ANALYST
LEGISLATIVE SOBS TO GO AHEAD AND
APPROACH. A AND BEGIN.
HER PRESENTATION THANK YOU SO
MUCH
.
TO I'M PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT FOR
YOUR DISCUSSION TODAY ON THE
TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND. INSIST
PACIFIC WE WILL BE PROVIDING AN
OVERVIEW OF THE TRIBAL GAMING
FUNDS HOW THE FISCAL CONDITION
OF THESE FUNDS HAVE CHANGED IN
RECENT YEARS TO ISSUE THE
RENEGOTIATION
COMPAQ.
AND THEN ALSO ESTIMATES FOR HOW
MUCH COULD BE DEPOSITED INTO A
COUPLE OF THESE FUNDS IN THE
FUTURE.
SO IN PRIOR YEARS GAMING
COMPACTS GENERALLY REQUIRE
TRIBES MAKE PAYMENTS INTO
VARIOUS STATE ACCOUNTS DEPENDING
ON CERTAIN CONDITIONS.
AND SO THESE ACCOUNTS WHERE THE
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND THE
HARDEST YAFFE
SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FIND THE
STF IN THE STATE GENERAL FUNDS.
THE SPECIFIC PAYMENT
REQUIREMENTS INTO EACH OF THESE
ACCOUNTS GENERALLY DEFERRED
ACROSS THE TRIBES AND DEPENDED
ON VARIOUS FACTORS INCLUDING THE
NUMBER OF MACHINES OPERATED. AS
WELL AS THE AVERAGE SLOT MACHINE
THAT WENT.
SO PAYMENTS THAT WERE DEPOSITED
INTO THE ARTIST YAFFE
ARE DISTRIBUTED TO CERTAIN
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES THAT
EITHER DO NOT OPERATE CASINOS OR
THAT OPERATE CASINOS WITH FEWER
THAN THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MACHINES.
IN EACH OF THESE TRIALS ARE
GENERALLY SUPPOSED TO RECEIVE
ALLOCATIONS ON ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE TWO WHEN
OUR STAFF WAS FIRST CREATED.
ANNUAL EXPENDITURES FROM THE
FINE WHO GENERALLY EXCEEDED
ANNUAL REVENUES.
PAYMENTS THEN DEPOSITED INTO THE
STF WERE GENERALLY AUTHORIZED
FOR FOR PURPOSES IN THE
FOLLOWING PRIORITY ORDER.
FIRST TO BACKFILL THOSE
SHORTFALLS IN OUR STF THAT I
JUST MENTIONED
SECOND FOR PROBLEM GAMING.
THIRD OF FOR REGULATORY COSTS
AND FOURTH PAYMENTS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT WERE IMPACTED
BY THE TRIBAL CASINOS THESE ARE
SOMETIMES KNOWN AS LOCAL
MITIGATION GRANTS.
SIMILAR TO THE RCF SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EATS NINE THE ANNUAL
EXPENDITURES FROM THE STF HAVE
GENERALLY EXCEEDED THE ANNUAL
REVENUES.
AND SO FINALLY CERTAIN TRIBES
WERE ALSO REQUIRED TO MAKE
PAYMENTS INTO THE STATE GENERAL
FUNDS.
IN THIS REALLY STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN EIGHT.
HOWEVER THE NINTH CIRCUIT COURT
OF APPEAL RULED IN THE RING CON
BAND VERSUS SCHWARZENEGGER CASE
THAT THESE TYPES OF PAYMENTS
WERE NOT PERMITTED.
SO IN ORDER TO ADDRESS ALL OF
THESE ISSUES THE STATE CHANGED
THE PAYMENT STRUCTURE THAT WERE
REQUIRED IN TRIBAL STATE COMPACT
THAT WERE RENEGOTIATED IN RECENT
YEARS.
SPECIFICALLY THE RE NEGOTIATED
COMPACTS REQUIRED INCREASED
PAYMENTS TO THE ARTIST YEAH. AND
AUTHORIZE THE TRANSFERS OF
MONIES THAT WERE NOT NEEDED TO
PROVIDE ALL ELIGIBLE TRIBES WITH
ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
THESE MONIES ARE THE ONES THAT
WOULD BE TRANSFERRED INTO THIS
NEW TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUNDS
WHICH YOU'LL BE HAVING FURTHER
DISCUSSION ABOUT TODAY.
SO THESE FUNDS AS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY WORD TO BE ALLOCATED
AS GRANTS TO TRIBES I EITHER DID
NOT OPERATE CASINOS ARE AHEAD
CASINOS WITH FEWER THAN THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MACHINES. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF SELF SUFFICIENCY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
THE RENEGOTIATE COMPAQ'S ALSO
ELIMINATED PAYMENTS TO THE
GENERAL FUND AND GENERALLY
SHIFTED MITIGATION OUR OTHER
PAYMENTS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AWAY FROM THE STF.
AND INSTEAD TRIES WERE GENERALLY
SUPPOSED TO REACH THEIR OWN
AGREEMENTS WITH THEIR RESPECTIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR THESE
TYPES OF PAYMENTS.
AS OF THIS TIME AND THAT THE STF
WOULD GENERALLY BE ONLY USED TO
FIND STATE REGULATORY OUR
PROBLEM GAMING COSTS.
SO A NUMBER OF THESE RENEGOTIATE
CONTACTS HAVE JUST RECENTLY GONE
INTO A FACT SO THE FULL IMPACT
OF THESE NEW TERMS ON PAYMENT
DEPOSITS INTO THE ARIAS TFR
GENERALLY UNCERTAIN.
PRELIMINARY ESTIMATES INDICATE
THAT ABOUT.
A HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION WILL
BE DEPOSITED INTO THE OUR STAFF
AND THAT ABOUT EIGHTY MILLION
WILL BE NEEDED TO PROVIDE
SEVENTY TWO ELIGIBLE TRIBES.
WITH THEIR FULL ALLOTMENT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THIS MEANS THAT ABOUT TWENTY TO
THIRTY MILLION COULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR TRANSFER INTO THE
TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUNDS.
AND THIS COULD BE THE CASE
ANNUALLY FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS
IN THE NEAR TERM. IN THE LONG
RUN THIS AMOUNT COULD
POTENTIALLY INCREASE TO EXCEED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS BUT THERE
IS SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY TO
THAT. I THINK AS TIME GOES ON
AND WILL BE TRACKING THOSE
REVENUE DEPOSITS WILL HAVE A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT THE FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE.
AND SO THE WITH THAT WILL
CONCLUDE OUR COMMENTS ARE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION AT THIS TIME WE'VE
BEEN JOINED.
BY SENATE.
GENERALIZATION SHARE OF THE
GERMAN DOG AND SO GO AHEAD AND
NOW MOVES TO HIM FOR SMOKING
REMARKS.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIRMAN GRAY AND
THANKS TO YOUR STAFF FOR A.
HELP ME PUT THIS COMMITTEE
TOGETHER IT COMMITTEE MEETING
TOGETHER JOINT COMMITTEE I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING LATE LOT
GOING ON THE CAPITAL THIS
MORNING. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE
GREAT RANCHERIA COMPACT IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE.
WAS THE FIRST COMPACT THAT
INCLUDED THE TRIBAL NATION
GRATIFIED.
AS THE CENTER WHO REPRESENTS
SECOND UNION ESPECIALLY THANKFUL
TO BE HERE TODAY IS THE CHAIR OF
THE SENATE GEO COMMITTEE.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT TODAY'S HEARING
HELPS OUR RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES
CRAFT LEGISLATION. THAT IS BOTH
FAIR AND RESPECTFUL OF TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY.
I'M ALSO LOOKING FORWARD TO
HEARING IDEAS ON HOW WE CAN
GUARANTEE THAT THE FUNDS WILL BE
USED TO EMPOWER TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS.
TO ADDRESS THE MANY NEEDS OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
GREAT AND THANKS IN ADVANCE ALL
THE WITNESSES WHO AGREED.
TO TESTIFY HERE TODAY.
OKAY AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS WILL GO AHEAD MOVE.
NOT FOR QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS IF ANYONE.
WOULD LIKE TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS
OF.
.
MS LEE WE CAN TAKE THOSE AT THIS
TIME.
SEEING I HAD I HAD รณ ON.
SENATOR DR NESTLE BECAUSE I WAS
A LITTLE BIT YOU MAY HAVE
ALREADY.
ANSWER THIS QUESTION BUT I'M
JUST MOVING FORWARD WE HAVE AN
IDEA OF HOW MUCH.
FUNDS WILL BE DEPOSITED IN.
THE TNG OFF ON A YEARLY BASIS.
ABSOLUTELY SO CURRENTLY.
A NUMBER OF THE RENEGOTIATE
COMICS HAVE JUST GONE INTO
EFFECT SO THE IMPACTS ARE STILL
LITTLE UNCERTAIN. BUT
PRELIMINARY ESTIMATES HAVE
INDICATED THAT ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND TEN MILLION WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR DEPOSIT INTO THE
RST HALF THE REVENUE SHARING
TRUST FUND. AND THAT ABOUT
EIGHTY MILLION OF THAT WILL BE
NEEDED TO PROVIDE THE ELIGIBLE
TRIBES WITH THEIR ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATIONS. SO
THIS MEANS THAT ABOUT TWENTY TO
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR TRANSFER INTO THE
TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUNDS.
THIS AMOUNT COULD INCREASE IN
FUTURE YEARS TO EXCEED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS BUT THERE IS
SOME UNCERTAINTY TO THAT AND SO
WE WILL BE MONITORING DEPOSITS
AND AS THE COMPLEX KIND OF
REALLY GOING TO AFFECT.
GREAT THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WHO ARE.
THANK YOU AND MS LAHAM WE WILL
MOVE TO ITEM THREE ON THE
AGENDA.
ASK BOTH JOE DILLON.
AND CRISTINA STARTED TO
APPROACH AND.
PROCEED WITH THEIR PRESENTATIONS
WATER OR HEAR FIRST FROM JOE
DILLON SENIOR ADVISER. FOR
TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS THE OFFICE
OF GOVERNOR BROWN.
WELCOME BACK WHICH DON'T.
WELL GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR THE FOR TAKING
THE TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULE TO TALK WITH THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC.
ALL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
OBJECTIVES HISTORY IN A BASIC
ASSEMBLY OF THE KIND BILL
LANGUAGE. TRIBAL ADVISORS.
SNYDER I WILL LOOK FORWARD AND
DISCUSS ISSUES RELATED TO
IMPLEMENTATION.
THAT THE GOAL OF THAT TRIBAL
NATION GRAND FUND IS TO GET
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO THE
GOVERNMENTS OF THE OUR STF
ELIGIBLE TRIBES IN A MANNER
THAT'S FAIR TO THE TRIBE TO
CONTRIBUTE. ABOUT.
AND FAIR AFFECTED AND RESPECTFUL
OF THE TRIBES THAT RECEIVE THOSE
FUNDS ABOUT WHEN THE THAT PEOPLE
AMENDED THE CONSTITUTION TO
ALLOW TRIBES IN AT THIS POINT
ONLY TRIBE TO OFFER CERTAIN
FORMS OF CLASS REGAINING THE
INTENT WAS TO ALL TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BENEFIT FROM.
FROM GAMING AS WE LOOK AROUND
THE STATE. I THINK WE CAN SAY
THAT FOR THE MOST PART IT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL I THINK THE NUMBERS
OF.
REVENUE GENERATED IS IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S ONE QUARTER OF ALL
THE REVENUE GENERATED IN THE
COUNTRY FROM TRIBAL GAMING THAT
THAT HAPPENS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE SEEN TRIBES MAKING
INVESTMENT IN THEIR FACILITIES
WHICH CREATES JOBS AND THEY'RE
ALSO MAKING MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
INVESTMENTS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
SO IT'S NOT JUST.
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE
BENEFITING BUT IT'S THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THOSE THOSE
GAMING FACILITIES ARE LOCATED.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE SUCCESS IS
NOT UNIFORM.
THAT.
THERE ARE HUNDRED NINE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FORTY
NINE OF THEM DON'T DO ANY
GAMING.
TWENTY THREE A LIMITED GAMING
OPERATIONS MEANING THEY HAVE
LESS THAN THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
SLOT MACHINES AND THEY MIGHT
CHOOSE TO DO THIS.
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS WHETHER
IT'S BECAUSE. THEY JUST DON'T
FOR THEIR VALUES TO THE LARGER
PRINCIPLES WANT ENGAGING GAMING
OPERATIONS OR BECAUSE THEY'RE
LOCATED. IN AN AREA WHERE
THERE'S NO MARKET FOR THIS KIND
OF ACTIVITY.
BUT THE GOAL OF THE TRIBAL
NATION GRANT FUND IS TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF THOSE SEVENTY TWO
TRIBES AND ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO AS THE PEOPLE ATTENDED
BENEFIT FROM FROM TRIBAL GAMING.
THE OUR STF WAS CREATED IN THE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE COMPAQ'S
WHICH.
PROVIDES THAT ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS WILL GO TO EACH
OF THOSE.
ELIGIBLE TRIBES.
IT.
.
THAT AMOUNT HASN'T CHANGED IN
FACT I CAN'T CHANGED IN THE
COMPACT LANGUAGE ITSELF IT
SPECIFIED THAT ANY MONEY THAT'S
PUT INTO THE ICE T. F.. BEYOND
WHAT'S REQUIRED TO MAKE THAT ONE
POINT ONE MILLION.
DB XIN MUST STAY IN THE FUND FOR
FUTURE YEARS SO IT SIMPLY ISN'T
AN OPTION TO TAKE THE ADDITIONAL
REVENUE INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
THE DISTRIBUTION THROUGH THE US
TO YEAH.
AS.
.
BUT CHAIRMAN INDICATED THE
GRADING COMPAQ WAS THE FIRST ONE
IN TWENTY TWELVE WHICH INCLUDED
THE TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND.
.
IT IS GENERAL LANGUAGE AND THE
INTENT WAS ALL ALONG TO ALLOW
FOR IMPLEMENTING LEGISLATION.
TO PROVIDE THE DETAILS OF HOW
THAT THE PROCESS WOULD WORK TO
ENSURE THAT THAT.
.
THE MONEY GOT TO THE TRIBES IT
NEEDED IT IN A WAY THAT WAS FAN
HAVE LEGITIMACY IN THE EYES OF
ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
.
TO GET THINGS MOVING AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE STARTED TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THAT BECAME MORE
INTENSE OF LAST YEAR. WE HAD A
NUMBER OF CONSULTATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND.
DEVELOPED DRAFT LANGUAGE WE
RECEIVED A LOT OF FEEDBACK A LOT
OF.
HELPFUL COMMENTARY ON HOW TO
MAKE IT BETTER AND WE PROVIDED
THAT TO THE OTHER STAFF. WHICH
IS WHAT IS NOW.
AB EIGHT EIGHTY AND I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT NONE OF US THINK
THAT THE CURRENT LANGUAGE IS
NECESSARILY PERFECT WE. WE
WELCOME ALL IDEAS ON HOW TO MAKE
IT BETTER WE JUST DON'T WANT UP
PERFECT TO BE THE ENEMY OF THE
GOOD IF THE MONEY. DOESN'T IF
THERE ISN'T A MECHANISM TO GET
THE MONEY OUT THE MONEY SITS AND
THAT DOESN'T DO ANYBODY ANY GOOD
SO WOULD LIKE TO NOW SHE'S
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
CURRENT.
BILL PROCESS.
FIRST OF ALL AND I THINK THIS
IS PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF IT S THAT TRIBAL
LEADERS WILL MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT. THE THE THE DETAILS OF
THE AMOUNT IMPLEMENTATION THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY ARE JUST
SIMPLY GOING TO BE MAKING THE
DECISIONS ABOUT. AWARDING THE
GRANTS ARE ALSO THE ONES WORKING
WITH THE TRIBAL ADVISER WHO WILL
ESTABLISH THE DETAILS OF THE
PROCESS.
THE BILL LAYS OUT CERTAIN
IMPORTANT.
PRINCIPLES SO THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE BUT THERE
LOT OF DETAILS AS THEIR
TYPICALLY I LEGISLATION THAT ARE
LEFT TO IMPLEMENTATION. HE'LL BE
TRIBAL LEADERS WORKING WITH THE
TRAVEL ADVISOR THAT WILL MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS.
AND.
THAT.
THE PROCESS IS A COMPETITIVE
APPLICATION PROCESS THAT'S
BECAUSE THE COMPAQ CLAIM WHICH
REQUIRES THAT IT BE A
COMPETITIVE APPLICATION PROCESS.
THE.
THE APPLICATION IS.
IN THE.
.
THE STATUTORY LANGUAGE INTENDED
TO BE A CONCISE APPLICATION
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT THESE ARE
TRIBES THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO SPEND A LOT OF
MONEY ON GRANT WRITING. THE
INTENT IS TO MAKE IT A CONCISE
SIMPLE APPLICATION THAT PRESENTS
THE INFORMATION THE DECISION
MAKERS NEED.
.
THE GAMMA CONTROL COMMISSION
WILL PROVIDE THE ASSISTANCE AND
AND PROCESSING THOSE AND
PRESENTING INFORMATION TO
DECISION MAKERS THE PURPOSE OF
OF.
THE THE GRANT IS.
IS VERY BROAD IN OTHER WORDS.
AT PRETTY MUCH ANY.
PURPOSE RELATING TO SOLVE
GOVERNMENTS DEVELOPING A SELF
DETERMINED COMMUNITY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IS WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF WHAT'S PERMISSIBLE
THE ONLY TWO AREAS WHERE.
GRANT FUNDS CANNOT BE USED TO
PRATAPADITYA ATTRIBUTIONS IN
GAMING. OF THE BILL.
STRIKE THE BALANCE I THINK
BETWEEN TRANSPARENCY AND
CONFIDENTIALITY THAT THE
MEETINGS OF THE PALACE STEPPED
BACK LOOKING OPEN MEETINGS ACT
WITH THE PROVISION TO ALLOW FOR
CLOSE SECTION.
DISCUSSION OF THINGS WHICH I
RELATE TO THE INTERNAL AFFAIRS
OF TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS OR
OTHERWISE SENSITIVE SUCH AS
FINANCIAL.
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TO ENSURE
THAT THE MONEY IS USED FOR THE
PURPOSES.
FOR WHICH THE THE AND MONEY
WITH SOCKS THE BUREAU OF
GAMBLING THE TROLL WILL BE. ABLE
TO DO.
AUDITS OF OF THOSE.
OF THOSE GRANT PROGRAMS AND IN
A MANNER THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH
GUIDANCE DEVELOPED BY BY THE
PANEL.
.
AND LIKE THE.
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND THAT
THE FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS WILL COME FROM THE
INDIAN GAMING SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION BUT.
AS WE.
HAVE WORKED THROUGH THE
CONSULTATION PROCESS WITH.
TRIBAL LEADERS THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS WHICH ARE
REYES EYES TWENTY SHARE THOSE
WITH YOU NOW I'M SURE YOU'LL
HEAR MORE LATER TODAY.
THE FIRST WAS THAT THE PROGRAM
IN THE TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND
IS DIFFERENT FROM THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND IS IS BASED
ON THE PRINCIPLE THAT. I THINK
THAT.
.
EACH TRIBE AS A SOVEREIGN TRIBAL
NATION IS IS EQUAL TO EVERY
OTHER TRIBE IN THAT THEY SHOULD
GET THE SAME BENEFIT AND I AND I
THINK WE RESPECT AND EMBRACE
THAT'S THAT PRINCIPLE THAT'S
WHY.
THREAT THAT WE NEGOTIATIONS THAT
THAT.
RESULTED IN A TRIBAL NATION
GRANT AND WE WE MADE IT CLEAR
THAT THE.
THE PRIMARY PURPOSE OF THE FUNDS
THAT GO INTO THIS POT WILL BE TO
DEFINE THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST
FUND AND IT'S ONLY IF THERE. IS
THAT FUND IS FULLY SOLVENT THAT
THERE WOULD BE MONEY THAT GOES
INTO THE TRIBAL NATION GRANT
FUND THE THINKING BEHIND THE
TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND IS
THAT.
.
RATHER THAN A MARGINAL INCREASE
AND FUNDING TO ALL THAT THAT.
INFUSION AND THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDS CAN
MAKE IT MORE IMPACTFUL LONGER
LASTING.
IMPACT ON A COMMUNITY OF SUCH
AS AN INVESTMENT HOUSING OR A
HOSPITAL OR OTHER SORTS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE MORE SO THAN A
MARGINAL INCREASE IN THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND.
AND.
THERE WERE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
COMPETITIVE. ASPECT TO TO THE
TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND.
WE AGAIN.
HAVE TRIED TO RESPOND TO THAT.
.
AND IN A WAY TO ENSURE THAT THE
THAT. THE PROCESS IS IS IS
SIMPLE AND. WELL AND THAT.
APPLICATION IS COULD.
YOU KNOW I I I SHOULD KNOW THAT
IN RESPONSE TO THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE THE REVENUE SHARING
TRUST FUND.
BEING AVAILABLE TO ALL WE HAVE
INCORPORATE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
WHICH WHICH.
EMPOWERS THE PANEL TO
DISTRIBUTE SOME BUT NOT ALL OF
THE FUNDS TO.
ALL.
TRIBE THAT HAVE APPLIED IF THEY
DETERMINE THAT TO BE THE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE USE OF THOSE
FUNDS AND WE BELIEVE THAT'S.
AS FAR AS WE CAN GO BUT IT
RESPONSE THIS CONCERNS AND STILL
CONSISTENT WITH. THE COMPACT
LANGUAGE THAT CONSTRAINS US.
.
AND FINALLY I THINK IT WILL.
THERE WERE.
.
WERE SOME CONCERNS THAT THE
INITIAL CONTACT THE GREAT
COMPACT INCLUDED THE TRIBAL
NATION GRANDSON BUT THAT THERE
WAS NO. OUT REACH BEFORE THAT I
THINK I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
NOT GOOD STATEMENT I THINK
THAT'S JUST REFLECTS THE FACT
THAT COMPAQ NEGOTIATIONS ARE
CONFIDENTIAL RECENTLY HAD. WE
CAN'T UNRING THAT BELL BUT WE'VE
CERTAINLY DONE OUR BEST TO TO
HAVE OUTREACH IN TERMS OF. OF
WHAT THE FUND IS AND HOW WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED.
.
THE.
THE FOCAL POINT WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF.
THE TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND
WILL BE THE TRIBAL ADVISER I
MEAN SHOULD BE WORKING WITH THE
BEGAN TO CONTROL COMMISSION THE
BJORK AND THE CONTROL. I SHOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
OUTSTANDING WITH THAT IF YOU
GOMEZ DID IS THE TRIBAL ADVISER
TO GET US TO THIS POINT AND THAT
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO HAVE
CRISTINA SNYDER.
.
TAKING ON THESE RESPONSIBILITIES
NOW AND SHE'S A GRADUATE OF UCLA
YOU SLAY LAW SCHOOL SHE'S WORK
AND TRIBAL ISSUES AND AND.
WASHINGTON DC AND AND HERE IN
THE STATE AND SHE IS A MEMBER OF
THE TRACTOR AND OF HOW MY NATION
SO WE'RE GRATEFUL TO HAVE FOR
BRINGING ALL OF THAT.
ISSUE AND OTHERS AND SO WITH
THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO TRAVEL
ADVISORS.
THANK YOU.
ACCEPTED THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
SERVING AS TRIBAL ADVISER
BECAUSE AS A MEMBER OF A
CALIFORNIA TRY I CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT THE ISSUES TROUBLING
PEOPLE'S FACE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND WANTED TO BE A PART
OF FACILITATING THE RELATIONSHIP
OF MUTUAL RESPECT AND
COLLABORATION BETWEEN.
TWO SOVEREIGNS.
WELL MULTIPLE SOVEREIGNS.
I'M SOMEONE WHO'S INSPIRED BY
CHALLENGES PARTICULARLY WHERE
THE OBJECTIVE IS WORTHWHILE.
GETTING ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO THE
GOVERNMENTS OF THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND ELIGIBLE
TRIBES IS AN INCREDIBLY
WORTHWHILE GOAL AND SOMETHING
WORTH DOING RIGHT.
WITH ADEQUATE TRIBAL AND PUT IT.
I KNOW THAT THEIR TRIBES THAT
SUPPORT THE TRIBAL NATION GRANT
FUND AND OTHERS WHO HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS.
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE LEADERS FROM EACH OF THESE
TRIBES TO IMPLEMENT THE TRIBAL
NATION GRANT FUND IN A MANNER
THAT IS FAIR EFFECTIVE
RESPECTFUL AND CONSISTENT WITH
THE APPLICABLE COMPAQ'S AND
IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS.
AND LEGISLATION.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION
IN HALF.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PRE SHOULD.
THE INTRODUCTION I THINK WE DO
HAVE.
.
SEVERAL QUESTIONS SHE MEMBERS.
ALL BEGIN.
BASKING GENERAL.
I KNOW THE RECENT COMPAQ SADDAM.
THE RESTRUCTURING THE PRINCIPLE
THAT GAMING TRIBES
SHOULD SHARE MORE REVENUE WITH
LIMITED OR NON GAMING.
.
IT WAS THIS PRECIPITATED BY A
JUDICIAL RULINGS BUT WHAT WAS
THE YOU KNOW. SERIES OF EVENTS.
YES SIR SO I THURMOND KIND
DECISION AS AS A NEED INDICATED
WAS. ISSUED IN TWENTY TEN I
THINK THAT I DROVE US TO TO
RETHINK.
HOW WE WOULD ENGAGE TRIBES IN
OUR NEGOTIATIONS AYE I THINK A
QUESTION THE? THE APPROACH OF OF
HAVING.
TRIBES CONTRIBUTE TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
WE'VE WE'VE FELT IN THE TRIBES
HAVE AGREED THAT THEY SHOULD
THOSE FUNDS THAT THAT THOSE
TRIBES THAT.
.
ARE ENGAGED IN GAMING.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY CAN AND
SHOULD SHARED THAT THE.
THE SUCCESS THAT THEY'RE HAVING
WITH OTHERS INCLUDING THOSE
TRIBES THAT AREN'T SO.
SO BLESSED WITH THE LOCATION OR
FREEWARE OR YOU KNOW LARGE MEDIA
POPULATIONS SO IT WAS PRIMARILY
DRIVEN BY.
.
A JUDICIAL DECISION AND AND
REVISITING OF OF OUR POLICY.
JR COULD YOU ALSO ON.
EXPLAIN HOW THE TRIBAL NATION
GRANT FROM DIFFERS.
FROM THE STF
RELATING TO.
TRIBES VERSUS DEAL WITH LOCAL
IRRIGATION AND ARM COMMUNITY
BENEFIT.
TYPE THING YES SIR IT'S STILL
ONE OF THE.
THE FOR SPECIFIED USES OF THE.
THE STF WAS FOR LOCAL
MEDICATION AND AND.
WHERE THERE WAS MONEY AVAILABLE
AND AND RECENTLY THERE HAS BEEN
MANY BUT IT WAS JUST SHOULD BE
THROUGH LOCAL BENEFIT COMMITTEES
FOR THE BENEFIT OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS?
?
THE THE BENEFICIARIES THEIR
DAMNED WORD NON TRIBAL ENTITIES
THEY WERE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THAT THAT TRIBAL NATION GRANT
FUND.
IS.
I THINK I'M A. ESSENTIALLY AN
EVOLUTION A A REFINEMENT. OF THE
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND THE
BENEFICIARIES OF TRIBES.
A IT IT'S MONEY THAT COMES FROM
TRIBES FOR TRIBES TO AND THAT'S
WHY THE APPROACH THAT WE'RE
TAKING HERE.
.
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT IN CERTAIN
RESPECTS THEN ABOUT WHAT WAS
DONE WITH THE STF WITH REGARD TO
THE LOCAL BENEFIT COMMITTEES.
BIGELOW.
THANK YOU ON.
TO DILLON.
WHAT HAPPENS IF THE BILL IS NOT
PASSED THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION
AND? ON THIS ISSUE.
AND WHAT HAPPENS TO THE FUNDS
THE MONEY JUST SITS THERE AND I
I I I IT WOULD IT WOULD NOT GO
TO THE BENEFIT OF OF THE TRIBES
IF IT'S PLACED IN THE* TF.
IT WOULD STAY IN THE US TF IT
WOULD INCREASE THE AMOUNT THAT'S
DISTRIBUTED TO THOSE TRIBES.
AND THE SECOND.
SINCE THE GREAT AND COMPACT TOO
ALL THE CONTACTS INCLUDE
PROVISIONS RELATED TO THE T. AND
G. F..
IF SO WAS THERE MUCH PUSH BACK
INCLUDING THOSE PROVISIONS
DURING THE COMPACT NEGOTIATIONS.
NO THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION ALL
OF THE CONTACT THAT WE'VE
NEGOTIATED INCLUDE TRIBAL NATION
GRANT FUND PROVISIONS.
WHEN.
I AYE THAT.
TRIBES UNDERSTAND THE POLICY
OBJECTIVES WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS
IN SOME OF OUR ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS ABOUT THE TRIBAL
NATION GRANT FUND A LET THAT THE
TRIBAL LEADERS WHO INVOLVED IN
THOSE DISCUSSIONS TALK ABOUT
THAT I MEAN CLEARLY THAT. THE
CONTACTS THAT WE HAVE CONCLUDED
TO THIS POINT. REFLECT AGREEMENT
BY THE PARTIES TO THOSE COMPACTS
THAT. THAT.
THE THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
COMPACT INCLUDING THE TRAVEL
AGENT GRANT FINDER THINGS WHICH
WE ALL SUPPORT.
CAN AND MAYBE FINALLY.
IT MIGHT BE A QUESTION THAT I
CAN ASK YOU AND THEN THE TRIBES
CAN BE PONDERING THIS QUESTION
AS WELL. DID YOU SEE ANY ISSUES
THAT MAY HAVE A ROSE THROUGH
THE.
THE ENTIRE PROCESS PROCESS LAST
YEAR DURING OUR CONSULTATIONS.
WHO WE WE HAVE WE TRY TO ADDRESS
THOSE YOU KNOW FOR INSTANCE
THAT'S WHY I WANTED TO GO?
THROUGH THE LIST OF OF OF OF
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED AND
HOW WE'VE TRIED TO TO RESPOND I
THINK.
.
YEAH AGAIN I THINK THAT.
THE CONCERNS A GENUINE AT AND
AND WE HAVE.
TRY TO IN GRAY ENGAGE ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND AND I THINK
THERE'S A DEFINITE NEED. TO TRY
TO GET.
FUND ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO THE
RCF ELIGIBLE TRIBES IN.
I I BELIEVE THAT WE'VE GOT A
LONG WAY TOWARDS ADDRESSING THIS
CONCERN.
IT MAY NOT BE PERFECT BUT I
THINK IT.
IT THE LEAST GIVES US SOMETHING
TO START I THINK IT'LL BE IN
GOOD HANDS AS FAR AS
IMPLEMENTATION AND CERTAINLY WE
CAN REVISIT ISSUES IF WE FIND
THAT.
DOWN THE ROAD THERE NEED TO BE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO THAT THE
BASIC FRAMEWORK
SO UNDERSTANDING THAT COMPARTE A
COMPONENT THAT LEADS ME.
TO THE TO THE QUESTION OF.
WHAT WE MAY HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION CURRENT?
LEE IN PLACE THAT SUPPORTIVE IN
EMBRACING OF THIS WHAT HAPPENS
IF THE.
AND THE NEXT ADMINISTRATION
COMING AND HAS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THOUGHT PROCESS AND
MAYBE ISN'T AS EMBRACING.
HOW DOES THIS BINDER NOT BUYING
THAT NEXT STEP?
WELL I I THINK THAT THAT THE
COMPACTS ARE A STATE THEY'VE
BEEN OUR STATE LAWS EVEN
RATIFIED IN PLACE OF GOVERNMENT
TO GOVERNMENT AGREEMENTS THAT
THAT BIND US I MEAN AND DOES
COMPACTS.
CREATE.
THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND
IN THE TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUNDS
THEY THEY HAVE THE THE THE
PURPOSES AND LIMITATIONS THAT
THOSE FUNDS HAVE SO ANOTHER
WHICH WE CAN INCREASE. THE THE
RCF BEYOND ONE POINT ONE MILLION
AND THE WAY THE COMPACTS RIGHT
NOW MONEY INTO THAT THAT'S IN
THOSE COMPACTS THAT INCLUDE THAT
TRIBAL NATION GRAPH AND WE'RE
GOING TO THAT FUND TO BE
AVAILABLE. THAT'LL BE BINDING ON
ON WHOEVER SITS IN AND IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND AND I
THINK THAT.
.
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO TO.
FOR LOTS OF REASONS ITHINK TO
TO HAVE A VEHICLE THAT ALLOWS US
TO MOVE THINGS FORWARD
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT IS ALREADY
STATE LAW.
DE AND SO SO THAT'S WHY WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET THAT
NOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY
JUST DOESN'T SIT THERE IT GETS
OUT OF THE TRIBES THAT NEEDED.
EXACTLY AND I THINK THAT'S A
CONCERN OF EVERYONE TO MAKE SURE
NO MATTER.
WHO'S SITTING IN THESE CHAIRS IN
THE FUTURE THE MONEY FOLLOWS
WHAT WAS INTENDED FROM. THESE
DAYS MOVING FORWARD SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT.
UTILIZED IN OTHER WAYS THAT
MAYBE WEREN'T IN AGREEMENT. YES
SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE SHOULD GO IF YOU COULD DATA.
OKAY AT THE CORE OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
AND THIS TOPIC IT SEEMS LIKE.
I LIKE TO HEAR YOUR PERSPECTIVE
ON RESPECTING SOVEREIGNTY RIGHT.
AYE IN THESE NEGOTIATIONS
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY OR WHATEVER
THE ULTIMATE OUTCOME OF
LEGISLATION IS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE IT'S CRAFT IN SUCH A
FASHION THAT WE.
YOUR ACHIEVE THESE GOALS YOU
FLAT OUT ABOUT THE SAME TIME.
AB ABSOLUTELY WOULDN'T
FRAMEWORK RESPECTING US ARMS
COULD YOU GIVE ME YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT. BUT YES SIR
I THINK A BIG PART OF IT IS
GOING TO BE THE ROLE THAT TRAVEL
ADVISOR SNYDER PLAYS I MEAN THE
REASON WHY. I THINK A LOT OF THE
DETAILS HAVE BEEN.
LEFT TO IMPLEMENTATION IS TO
ENSURE THAT THE TRIBAL LEADERS
WORKING WITH THE TRAVEL ADVISOR
ABLE TO PUT THOSE DETAILS INTO
PLACE THAT THAT RESPECTS I
THINK.
NOT THE LEGITIMATE INTERESTS OF
OF ALL THE TRIBES IN THE STATE
THAT WENT TO GENERATE CONTRIBUTE
THE MONEY AND THE ONES WHO
RECEIVE IT NOT TO HAVE A PROCESS
THAT HAS LEGITIMACY IN THEIR
EYES.
SO THAT'S WHY WE.
UP INTENDED TO HAVE LEGISLATION
THAT. IT REFLECTED THE INPUT OF
OF TRIBES IN THE STATE AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE.
WORKED HARD TO TRY DE GET THAT
INPUT AND CLEARLY AT WE CAN'T
TAKE EVERY INPUT INTO ACCOUNT IN
THE BILL WITH THERE ARE CERTAIN
CONSTRAINTS BUT BUT I THINK. I
THINK IN MY MIND.
IT'S THE AT RESPECTFUL
ENGAGEMENT INCLUSION OF.
OF TRIBAL LEADERS IN MAKING
DECISIONS THAT FOR RESPECTS
THEY'RE ON A LEGITIMATE ROLE IN
THIS PROCESS.
FORMERLY IT MY ROLES JUST GONNA
BE TO FACILITATE THESE
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN SOVEREIGN
LEADERS AND SO ON.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THE WAY
THAT THE LEGISLATION IS ALREADY
DRAFTED RESPECTS THE IDEA THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DISCUSSIONS
THAT ARE.
YOU KNOW.
BEST LEFT TO BE BETWEEN
SOVEREIGN LEADERS AND NOT FOR
THE PUBLIC AND I THINK THAT THAT
REALLY RESPECTS A LOT OF THE
COMMENTS AND FEEDBACK THAT WE
GOT PRIOR TO IT TO THE
LEGISLATION BEING DRAFTED. BUT.
I WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
MY ROLE IS NOT. AS PUPPETMASTER
IT'S REALLY JUST BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY ARE THEY ARE FOLLOWING
THEIR OWN RULES AND THAT THERE
ARE.
RESPECTING THESE PRINCIPLES OF
SOVEREIGNTY.
I APPRECIATE THAT ARE CERTAINLY
I THINK THE ADDITION OF THE
PROVISION.
BEFORE THE TRIAL ADVISER IN THE
PLEDGE
AND WAS A MAJOR STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
IN PROVIDING THAT FORUM WITH
WHICH TO HAVE THOSE RESPECTFUL.
DISCUSSIONS.
SO.
I APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER ANY
OTHER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERSHIP THIS TIME.
SEEING THEN WHY DON'T WE GO
AHEAD AND.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS
AND AND MOVE ON TO ITEM FOR ON
THE AGENDA.
AND ASK.
ALL OF THE PRESENTERS.
TO.
APPROACH TO DANCE AND PREPARE
YOUR PRESENTATION
WELCOME CHAIRMAN.
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE.
MY NAME IS SCOTT COZART NINE
HAVE THE HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TO
BE THE TROUBLE CHAIRMAN OF THE
SUBURBAN BAND W. SANYO INDIANS.
WE'RE LOCATED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AT THE FOOTHILLS OF THE SAN
JACINTO MOUNTAINS AND ON THE
BANKS OF THE SIGNS ON THE RIVER.
THE SABAH TRIBE IS GOVERNED BY
AN ELECTED FIVE MEMBER TRIBAL
COUNCIL. AND WE OPERATE A CASINO
UNDER THE NINETEEN NINETY NINE.
TRIBAL STATE COMPACT GAMING
COMPACT.
TODAY.
AS REPRESENTATIVES OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU ARE HERE TO LISTEN AND
HOPEFULLY TO LEARN.
AS CHAIRMAN OF THE TRIBE I'M
HERE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE
VIEWS OF THE SUBURBAN TRIED.
AND OUR OPPORTUNITIES FOR A
BRIGHTER FUTURE.
IF YOU CHAIR THAT REQUIRES A
RENEWED. TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT.
PARTLY A COMPACT WITH MUTUALLY
AGREED UPON TERMS THAT FURTHER
ADVANCES.
OUR SELF DETERMINATION.
AND SELF GOVERNANCE NEEDS FAR
INTO THE FUTURE.
AS SUCH THE SOBELL LISSOUBA
TRIBE APPRECIATES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON THE TRIBAL NATIONS
GROUND FUN.
WILL ALSO SUBMIT WRITTEN
COMMENTS FOR THE FORMER RECORD
AS WELL.
THE TRIBE FIRMLY BELIEVES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MUST CLARIFY.
THE PURPOSE AND EFFECT OF THE
TNG OUT AND THERE'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS A GOOD
START.
OVERALL WE THINK IT IS PREMATURE
TO ADVANCE ANY LEGISLATION
REGARDING THE DISTRIBUTION OF
TRIBAL GAMING FUNDS WITHOUT
ADEQUATE CONSULTATION.
AND CONSIDERATION OF THE MERITS
OF ANY PROPOSED TNG F.
IMPROVEMENT IMPLEMENTATION
SCHEME.
CONSULTATION AFTER THE FACT IS
NOT CONSULTATION.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THE TRIBE IS
CURRENTLY A PARTY TO THE TN GF.
THE SUBURBAN TRIBAL SEARCH OUR
SOVEREIGN INTEREST IN THE
CREATION OF A STATE BUREAUCRATIC
ENTITY HOWEVER BENEVOLENT.
THAT MAY IMPOSE OR INFRINGE ON
OUR TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY.
SECOND THE SUBURBAN TRIBE HAS NO
OBJECT OBJECTION TO SOME OF OUR
TRIBAL GAMING REVENUES BEING
DISTRICT DISTRIBUTED.
TO THOSE IDENTIFIED ELIGIBLE
TRIBES.
IN FACT A TRIBALLY DRIVEN
TRIBALLY CREATED.
PROCESS TO DO JUST THAT WAS
CREATED IN THE NINETEEN NINETY
NINE COMPAQ.
PROCESS KNOWN AS THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND.
AS SET FORTH IN THE NINETY NINE
COMPAQ R. STF RECOGNIZES THE
DESIRE OF THE CALIFORNIA TRIBES
TO CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
TRIBES IN THE STATE.
DAR ES GEF CONCEPT WAS CREATED
TO SHARE REVENUES WITH THOSE
TRIBES LANDS OR CIRCUMSTANCES
PROHIBITED SIZEABLE CASINOS.
SINCE THE VERY BEGINNING THE
SUBURBAN TRIBE HAS CONTRIBUTED
TO THE RSC HAVE BOTH DIRECTLY IN
THE FORM OF GAMING DEVICE
LICENSES FEES.
AND INDIRECTLY.
THROUGH PAYMENTS UNDER THE
SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FUND
SHORTFALL PROCESS.
Q. TO OUR TRIBE SUPPORT TO THE
RST F. WAS THE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS TO THOSE
IDENTIFIED ELIGIBLE TRIBES.
SOME MOBILE TRIBE ALSO SUPPORTED
EACH RECIPIENT TRIBE'S SOVEREIGN
RIGHT. TO ASSESS ITS OWN NEEDS.
AND SET ITS OWN PRIORITIES.
OUR TRIBE WILL NOT SECOND GUESS
OR MICRO MANAGE OTHER SOVEREIGNS
TRIBAL PRIORITIES.
AFTER HISTORY OF BROKEN PROMISES
THE NEGLIGENCE BY BOTH THE
FEDERAL AND STATE GOVERNMENTS
THE SMOKE A TRIBE IS NOT GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE OUR JUDGMENT OR
ACT LIKE IT.
PATERNALISTIC TRUSTEE OF THE OUR
STF.
INSTEAD WE ADVOCATE THAT
SOVEREIGNTY IS A SOVEREIGNTY
DEBTS.
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE RESPECTED
EACH OF THE ELIGIBLE TRIBES
RIGHTS AND WE CONTINUE TO DO
THAT TODAY NO STRINGS ATTACHED
TO THEIR SOVEREIGNTY.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT IMPORTANT
EXCUSE ME?
WELL THE ENVISIONED TN.
GEE UP PROCESS PUT SIMPLY IS
PATERNALISTIC AT HIS VERY CORE.
RATHER THAN SEEK LEGAL PATHWAYS
TO EQUALLY DISTRIBUTE THOSE
FUNDS AND THE ARTIST YOU HAVE OR
SIMILAR TN G. UP PROCESS.
THE SUGGESTED IMPLEMENTATION
PLANS SEEK TO DIVIDE ELIGIBLE
TRIBES CREATING COSTLY
COMPETITION AND PREDICTABLE
INEQUITY.
IN ADDITION THE TNG F. PROCESS
MAY CREATE A CUMBERSOME AND
COMPLICATED ADMINISTRATIVE
BUREAUCRACY.
A NEW BRIATORE SEE DOES NOT.
PENSKE'S MEN NEW BUREAUCRACY NOT
SEEN IN INDIAN COUNTRY.
SINCE THE FEDERAL CREATION OF
THE BUREAU OF INDIAN AFFAIRS.
TO BE CLEAR THIS MOBILE TRIBAL
HISTORY AND EXPERIENCE FOR THE
FEDERAL BUREAUCRACY OUR TRUSTY.
IS NOT ONE WE SEEK TO MIRROR.
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
WE ARE NOT LOOKING TO CREATE A
MANY BE AYE.
AT THE STATE AND QUITE FRANKLY
THE STATE SHOULD WANT TO EITHER.
SIMPLY PUT ANY INSERTION OF A
SAVINGS CLAUSE.
AND LEGISLATION TO DISAVOW A
TRUST RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
TRIBE.
IN THAT ADMINISTRATION OF THE
TNG F. WILL NOT RELEASED THE
STATE FROM RESPONSIBILITY OR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THAT'S GIVEN THE HISTORICAL
FAILURES OF THE FEDERAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENTS TO FULFILL THE
PURPOSE AND INTENT OF THE
TREATIES THE CONSTITUTION AND
STATUTES.
THE SUBURBAN DRIVE SIX A
STREAMLINED APPROACH TO THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE TNG UP. BY
REDUCING THE TIME AND MONEY
SPENT ON A LENGTHY BUREAUCRATIC
PROCESS.
FOR DESPITE OUR SUCCESS THE
SUBURBAN TRIBE NOT UNLIKE
VIRTUALLY EVERY TRIBE IN THE
NATION INCLUDING OUR AS. ANTI
NGF ELIGIBLE TRIBES CONTINUES TO
NEED MORE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE HOUSING
EDUCATION.
JUDICIAL SYSTEMS HEALTHCARE AND
SOCIAL SERVICES.
THE ECONOMIC NEED INTO COUNTRY
IS SELF EVIDENT THEREFORE
ELABORATE DISTRIBUTION PROCESS
IS NOT NECESSARY.
RATHER WE BELIEVE THE TNG AFTER
SUBMISSION PROCESS PROCESS
SHOULD REMAIN SIMPLE AND
INEXPENSIVE LIKE OUR STF
PROCESS.
FURTHER IT SHOULD REMAIN FAIR
AND EQUITABLE THE SHOULD BE
DISTRICT DISTRIBUTED ON A
PREDICTABLE SCHEDULE FOR
PLANNING AND THE SHOULD BE SPENT
ON TRAVEL BATES PRIORITIES.
IN CLOSING OUR RESERVATION THE.
ON OUR RESERVATIONS OVER TRIBE
HAS CREATED A LOCAL ECONOMY.
DESPITE THE LOSS OF THE
RESERVATION ON WATER SUPPLY FOR
DECADES.
THE HISTORICAL WRONGS HAVE MADE
THIS MOBILE PEOPLE STRONGER AND
BETTER PREPARED TO FACE THE NEXT
CHALLENGE SHORT TRAVEL
SOVEREIGNTY.
BUT THE SUBURBAN TRIBAL COUNCILS
QUESTS ISABEL WELL BEYOND SIMPLY
BEING ABLE TO OPEN BUSINESSES
AND CREATE JOBS.
RATHER THE TRIBAL STRENGTHEN OUR
COMMUNITIES BY ADVANCING THE
OVERALL WELL BEING OF OUR
PEOPLE.
INCLUDING OUR SISTER CALIFORNIA
TRIBES.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE JOINT COMMITTEE TO FIND A
WORKABLE SOLUTION.
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST
LOCAL WILL SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY.
THANK CHAIRMAN.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME'S DAN ALSO GOTTA I'M THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE EQUIPMENT OF
INDIANS ALSO THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE.
CT A SEED TO CONTACTED TRIBE
STEERING COMMITTEE WHICH IS
ABOUT COMPRISE ABOUT TWENTY
TRIBES.
.
ORIGINALLY AS ESTABLISH THE
NINETEEN NINE NINE COMPAQ'S.
.
IT UNION RIGIDLY THE NINE AYE
COMPACT ESTABLISHED THE.
THERE ARTIST YOU HAVE REGIONALLY
ENDING HAS CONTINUED EVER SINCE
YOU KNOW THAT EVERY TRIBE
OPERATING THREE IN A FIFTY FIVE
THREE ARE PRETTY DEVICES. IS
ELIGIBLE FOR THE ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
ANY SURPLUSES TO BE ROLLED OVER
TO SUBSEQUENT YEARS IF THERE'S A
SHORTFALL.
THAT IS TO BE MADE UP BY THE
STF OR OTHERWISE THE AMOUNT OF
THE AS FAR AS TO HAVE IS TO BE
DISTRIBUTED TO ALL ELIGIBLE
TRIBES IN EQUAL SHARES.
AS OUR STATE IS CURRENTLY
ESTABLISHED THERE'S NO MECHANISM
FOR DISTRIBUTING ANY SURPLUS AND
IN THE RTF UNTIL NOW. THERE HAS
NOT BEEN AN ISSUE BECAUSE OUR
STF WAS IN A PERPETUAL
SHORTFALL.
BUT NEWT BUT THE NEW BROWN
ADMINISTRATION COMPACTS WHICH
HAVE A LIMITED LIMITED.
THE GAMING DEVICE LICENSING
SYSTEM THAT WAS PRIMARY SOURCE
FOR FINDING GARCIA.
HAVE CREATED A STRONG LIKELIHOOD
THAT THERE'S A SURPLUS IN OURS.
AND OURS JEFF IN THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE.
THE US IS.
THE PROFESSOR PURPOSES OF THE T.
NGF IS TO CREATE A MECHANISM FOR
DISTRIBUTING ANY SURPLUS AND AND
ARTIST YOU HAVE RATHER THAN
ROLLING OVER THE MONIES.
FOR FUTURE YEARS BY SPILLING ANY
SURPLUS AND TO THE G. NGF IN
AWARDING GRANTS TO RCF ELIGIBLE
TRIBES.
THE STATE HASN'T IDENTIFIED
WHICH TRIBES IF ANY HAD ANY
INPUT. IN THE CONCEPT OF THE TNG
F. OR THE FOR GOING CONTACT
LANGUAGE IT FIRST APPEARED IN
THE GRAIN COMPACT.
BUT WITHOUT THE SPILLOVER
LANGUAGE.
THAT WAS ADDED LATER.
IN LATER COMPLEX INSTANCES BEEN
AMENDED TO THE GREEN COMPACT.
HOWEVER NO BURKE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION COMPAQ SPELLS OUT
THE PROCESS OR CRITERIA. BY
WHICH GRANTS ARE TO BE AWARDED
OR BY WHOM GRANT APPLICATIONS
ARE TO BE REVIEWED AND APPROVED.
OR HOW OR BY WHOM GRANT
REVIEWERS APPROVE OR APPROVALS
ARE TO BE SELECTED.
AS ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED.
AB AT CONFLICTING TAINT KNOW
MORE DETAILS THAT ARE CONTAINED
IN THE VARIOUS COMPACTS THAT
REFER TO THE TNG ERA.
THE STATE PREPARED CONCEPTUALIZE
OF HOW THE T. NGF WOULD. BE
ADMINISTERED BUT THE PROPOSAL
WAS MET BY STRONG OPPOSITION
FROM A SIGNIFICANT.
NUMBER OF OUR FIRST YOU HAVE
ELIGIBLE TRIBES AND VARYING
DEGREES OF SUPPORT FROM OTHER
TRIBES.
THE COMPAQ STEERING COMMITTEE.
CONSISTENT ABOUT TWENTY TWENTY
MEMBER TRIBES.
IS STRONGLY OPPOSED.
AB AT HAS BEEN AMENDED TO FLESH
OUT SOME OF THE DETAILS OF HOW
THE T. NGF WOULD WORK.
THE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS SOME BUT
ONLY A RELATIVELY FEW OF THOSE
PROVISIONS DEEMED.
MOST UNACCEPTABLE TO BY NEARLY
ALL TRIBES IS THAT FOR THOSE
THAT ENDORSED THE JINJA.
FOR EXAMPLE THE BILL NO LONGER
GRANTS MATERIALS SUBJECT TO
DISCLOSURE ON THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT AND NO LONGER REQUIRES
RECIPIENT TRIBES TO WEIGH THE
SOVEREIGN IMMUNITY WHICH WE
APPRECIATE THESE AMENDMENTS.
HOWEVER CONTINUES TO CONTEMPLATE
COMPETITIVE PROCESS FOR GRANTS
FOR LIMITED RANGE OF PURPOSES
JUST.
SORRY DOES DIRECTLY LIMITING
TRIES RIGHT TO SELF
DETERMINATION AND ALSO REQUIRES
OUGHT TO BE CONDUCTED.
DESPITE ITS LIMITATIONS GARCIA
HAS HAD FOUR PRIMARY VIRTUES
FOR ELIGIBLE TRIBES.
FIRST USED
THE DISTRIBUTION PROCESS WAS
SIMPLE TO ADMINISTER.
SECOND ALL THOSE CAPPED AT ONE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS EACH
TRIBE RECEIVED AN EQUAL AMOUNT
AND US ALLOCATIONS ARE FAIR AND
EAT.
A TO ALL ELIGIBLE TRIBES.
THIRD AS YOU SEE IT OF THE
DISTRIBUTIONS.
IS PREDICTABLE.
ENABLING RECIPIENT TRIBES TO
PLAN FOR THE RECEIPT OF THE
FUNDS.
AND THE USE OF THOSE FUNDS.
FINALLY IT RESPECTS THE RIGHT
OFEACH RECIPIENT TRIBE TO SET
ITS
OWN PRIORITIES AND DETERMINE HOW
BEST TO MEET ITS OWN NEEDS WITH
NO STRINGS ATTACHED AND HOW THE
FUNDS ARE TO BE SPENT.
OTHER THAN CREATING A MECHANISM
BY WHICH THE SURPLUS AN ARTIST
YOU HAVE CAN BE DISTRIBUTED.
RATHER THAN ROLLING OVER FREE
FUTURE YEARS.
THE PROCESS PROPOSED BY ABA
EIGHTY DOES NOT PRESERVE ANY OF
THE VIRTUES OF THE RCF. AND IF
THE TNG EFFORTS TO DISTRIBUTE
MONIES BY AWARDING GRANTS ON THE
COMP UNCOMPETITIVE BASES.
FOR SPECIFIED PURPOSES AS
DETERMINED BY CUMBERSOME AND
COMPLICATED ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS THOSE VIRTUES CAN'T BE
PRESERVED.
FOR EXAMPLE.
THE QUEEN RESTORATION CONSISTS
OVER NINETEEN THOUSAND ACRES
LOCATED IN THAT NEAR TOWN OF
ANZA IN A FAIRLY REMOTE AND.
LIGHTLY POPULATED.
AREA GROUPS SAY COUNTING THAT'S
NOT EASY TO GET TO.
ALTHOUGH WE OFFERED TO SMOGGY
GAMING FACILITY.
THEY CANNOT GENERATE ANYTHING
CLOSE TO WHAT THE TROUBLE
GOVERNMENT IN THE RESERVATION
COMMUNITY NEEDS AND. WAY
PROGRAMS IN INFRASTRUCTURE.
ALTHOUGH BLESSED WITH MORE LAND
THAN MANY CALIFORNIA TRIBES THE
CREW RESERVATIONS ROADS AREN'T
PAVED.
IT DOESN'T HAVE A COMMUNITY
WATER SEWAGE SYSTEM MUCH OF THE
RESERVATION HOUSE DOG COULD USE
IMPROVEMENT AND THE RESERVATION
RESIDENTS. HAVE TO TRAVEL FAR
FOR MANY GOOD FOR MANY GOOD
SERVICES AND EMPLOYMENT.
THE QUIZ SITUATION IS NOT UNIQUE
CRITICALLY AMONG TRIBES THAT ARE
NOT LOCATED NEAR MAJOR
POPULATION CENTERS OR NEAR MAJOR
HIGHWAYS.
THAT'S WHY KOREA AMONG MANY
OTHER TRIBES HAS BEEN AND WILL
LIKELY RETURN WILL REMAIN.
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
DISTRIBUTIONS FROM THE OURS TIA.
WHO'S A MEMBER OF THE.
OF THE COMPLEX DURING COMMITTEE.
A COALITION OF TWENTY TRIED TO
HAVE BEEN JOINED TOGETHER TO
NEGOTIATE REPLACEMENTS.
MOST OF THE CDS THE CHARGES ARE
ELIGIBLE FOREST YES.
DISTRIBUTIONS AND AGREE THAT
ANY SURPLUS IN RCF SHOULD BE
DISTRIBUTEDTO ALGEBRA BILLS
WILL TRIBES IN EQUAL SHARES.
AS A SURPLUS THE CRUISE
RATHER THAN SIMPLY ROLLING THEM
OVER FOR FUTURE YEARS.
WHICH ARE CURRENT COMPAQ SEATS.
ALTHOUGH CUI WAS NOT CONSULTED
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
CONCEPT WITH TNG HAVE WE
UNDERSTAND THE MAIN PURPOSE IS
TO PROVIDE A MEANS FOR
DISTRIBUTING RSTS.
SURPLUS RATHER THAN ROLLING
OVER.
HOWEVER QUEER ALONG WITH THE
REST THE CTS THE TRIBES OPPOSE
GREATNESS SYSTEM WHICH TRIBES
MUST COMPETE FOR GRANTS.
TO BE AWARDED BY A BUREAUCRACY
EVEN IF.
ONE ELECTED AMONG TRIBAL LEADERS
THOUGH HOW THE POWER TOWARD
MONEY BASED ON A SUBJECTIVE
JUDGMENTS.
ABOUT WHICH TRIED NEEDS AND
PRIORITIES ARE MORE URGENT AND
LEGITIMATE AND OTHER TRIBES.
VIRTUALLY EVERY ARTIST YET BILLS
WHICH I'VE HAS MAJOR. AND
IMMEDIATE NEEDS RATHER.
WHETHER THEY LACK.
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
IF STRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT
INADEQUATE LAND BASE HOUSING
EDUCATION JUDICIAL SYSTEM OF.
EDUCATION HEALTHCARE SOCIAL
SERVICE AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS
THAT PEOPLE.
NEED AND EXPECT FROM THE
GOVERNMENT'S.
THIS WILL MAKE ESTABLISHING
GRANT CARTERI IN EXCEEDINGLY
DIFFICULT AND INQUISITIVE IN
UNNECESSARY TESTS.
FOR ONE EXAMPLE IN.
THE TRIBE WITH A LARGE.
BUT REMOTE LAND BASE AND
RELATIVELY SMALL POPULATION HAVE
A GREATER NEEDS IN A REMOTELY
LOCATED DRIVE WITH THE SMALL AND
BASS IN A RELATIVELY LARGE
POPULATION.
CALIFORNIA'S TRIBES AND
RESERVATION COMMUNITIES ARE TOO
DIVERSE.
FOR ANY IT AND SEE ALSO ANY
ENTITY EXTERNAL TO THE TRIBE
ITSELF TO WAY ONCE TRIED CERTAIN
DANCE IS AGAINST ANOTHER.
FOR THESE REASONS QUEER
SUGGESTED THE TNG ERA
RESTRUCTURED SO OF RESERVES WHAT
WE REGARD AS THE GREATEST
VIRTUES OF THEIR* CHIA.
THE DISTRIBUTION PROCESS BE OF
SIMPLE TO ADMINISTER.
IT SHOULD BE FAIR TO ALL
ELIGIBLE TRIES MEANING EACH
RECIPIENT TRIBE SHOULD RECEIVE
THE SAME OUT WHEN THE FUNDS ARE
DISPUTE JUST DISPERSED.
SCHEDULE FOR MAKING JUST
RESTAURANTS SHOULD BE
PREDICTABLE ENABLE ENABLING
RECIPIENT TRIBES TO PLAN FOR THE
RECEIPT AND USE OF FUNDS.
THE RIGHT OF EACH IT RECIPIENT
TRIBE TO SET ITS OWN NEEDS A
PARTY SHOULD BE RESPECTED.
THE ONLY APPLICATION SHOULD BE
TIMELY SUBMISSION OF A LETTER
DOCUMENT THE TRIBES ELIGIBILITY
REQUESTS DISBURSEMENT OF EQUAL
SHARES OF T. NGF.
DISBURSEMENTS.
HAD THERE BEEN MEANINGFUL
CONSULTATION WITH THE ALIFORNIA
TRIES WHEN TINA JEFF WAS BEING
CONCEIVED.
THE TASK OF DEVISING AN
APPROPRIATE STRUCTURE WOULD HAVE
BEEN MUCH EASIER LESS
CONTROVERSIAL.
HOWEVER.
WE APPRECIATE THE GEO.
CHAIRS EFFORTS
TO FIND A FAIR AND WORKABLE
SOLUTION TO SITUATION NOT THEIR
OWN MAKING.
I'LL BE HAVE A QUEER AND THE CDS
MEMBER TRIBES APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND LOOK FOR DISMISSING AND
DEVELOPING THE SOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M CHAIRMAN WHY NOT THE SECOND
TICKET ENTRANCE REAL I'M NOT
GOING TO READ. MY ENTIRE LETTER
AS CHAIRMAN DANIEL.
AIRPORT OUR OPPOSITION IS
ALMOST IDENTICAL AND WITH.
WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE? WITH
THE WAY THE TEAM JEFF.
GOES ON SALINAS READ THIS A
LITTLE PART OF IT.
I'M RUNNING FOR THE.
I'M RUNNING TO THE STATE MY
TRIBAL COUNCILS OPPOSITIONS THE
TROUBLE NATION'S GRANT FUND.
AND THE PAST PASSES OF AB EIGHT
EIGHTY.
THE TRIBE IS A FEDERAL FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED INDIAN TRIBE ORGANISE
EYES. ORGANIZED UNDER A WRITTEN
CONSTITUTION WHICH DELEGATES A
CHICKEN RANCH TRIBAL COUNCIL AS
A GOVERNMENT BODY OF THE TRIBE.
THE TRIBE IS A BENEFICIAL OWNER
THE CHICKEN RANCH INDIAN
RESERVATION LOCATED ATOMIC
COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
THE TRIBE IS ALSO THE OWNER AND
OPERATOR OF A SMALL CASINO THE
CONSISTS OF THREE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE GAMING DEVICES.
THE TRIBE IS PART OF THE COMPACT
DRIVE STEERING COMMITTEE THAT IS
CURRENTLY IN THE COMPAQ
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
I AM WRITING TO INFORM HIM THAT
THE TRIBE OPPOSES THE INCLUSION
OF THE OF THE TNG OF AND THE
TRIBES COMPACT. AND THE PASSES
OF A BAT FOR ALL THE REASONS SET
FORTH IN THE CTS HE'S LETTER
DATED. AUGUST ELEVENTH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO CHAIRMAN GREG.
SO.
WITHOUT.
I LOOK FORWARD.
TWO ALTHOUGH.
PROPOSITIONS AND I SAID.
TERMS AGO KNOWN GERMAN DANIEL.
WITHOUT WOULD LIKE SEE.
THE TEAM JEFF CALLED EVENLY
TOURISTS THE TRIBES SO I DON'T
WANT TO WASTE ANY.
MORE GUYS THIS TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
HELLO.
I'M THE TROUBLE CHAIRMAN FOR THE
COUNTY VALLEY BAND OF POMO
INDIANSAND ALSO THE CHAIRMAN
FOR UNITED POLLINATION COUNCIL.
WHICH CONSIST OF SIXTEEN TRIBES
IN LAKE MENDOCINO CINEMA
COUNTIES.
ALL THOSE TRIBES WILL MOST
LIKELY QUALIFY OTHER THAN ONE
FOR THE TRIBAL NATIONS GRAND
FUN.
WE HAVE TWO OFFICIAL STANCES.
THE FIRST IS MITCHELL STATUS IF
IT'S GOING TO BE A GRANT
PROCESS.
IS THAT THE TRIBAL LEADERS
DECIDE.
WHAT TRIED WILL BE AWARDED THOSE
DOLLARS?
WE KNOW OUR COMMUNITY BETTER
THAN ANYBODY ELSE SO THAT. THAT
WAS A BIG ONE FOR US BUT ALSO.
SECOND OFFICIAL PLEASED WE JUST
MET YESTERDAY WAS.
NO MATTER WHAT DIFFERENCES WE
MAY HAVE IN OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES OR THE
POLITICS YOU HAVE WHEN YOU'RE
AND.
THAT WE'VE WE ASK DON'T MATTER
WHAT.
THAT THIS BILL GET PASSED THIS
YEAR.
WE HAVE TRIBES THAT ARE
SUFFERING LIKE YOU WILL NEVER
EVER SEEN IN YOUR LIFE.
IN YOUR LIFE.
IF YOU GUYS WERE TO VISIT SOME
OF THE RESERVATIONS THAT I HAVE
WITNESSED.
IT'S VERY SAD.
VERY SAD.
NOW AS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE KIND
OF ALL THE BAND OF POMO INDIANS.
MY POSITION IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN MY COLLEAGUES
THAT SIT HERE WITH ME.
I HAVE.
LET ME GIVE A A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ABOUT COYOTE VALLEY.
THROUGH NEW MARKET TAX CREDITS.
THROUGH THE LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDITS
THROUGH FEDERAL GRANTS.
AND SELF FUNDING.
BY THE END OF TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN.
WE ILL BUILD BUILDING A SMALL
NEW CASINO.
THREE HUNDRED FORTY NINE GAMES.
WE WILL BE WILL BUILDING HUNDRED
A ONE HOTEL ROOM.
WE JUST REMODELED THIRTY BRAND
NEW HIGH BRED TO PRACTICALLY
BRAND NEW HUD HOMES.
WE WOULD BUILDING THIRTY NEW
HOMES.
WE WILL BUILDING OUR NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR ON WASTE IN
OUR OWN WATER. AS WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE STRUGGLE.
CITIES.
WE'RE DOING THAT.
ONLY BECAUSE.
S. COMPETITIVE GRANTS ARE
AVAILABLE LARGE AMOUNTS.
CANNOT BUILD.
THE GYMNASIUM.
YOU CANNOT BUILD A NEW TROUBLE
GOVERNMENT OFFICE.
YOU CAN EVEN BUILD ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OR ROADS.
IF WE DISTRIBUTE THE MONIES
EVENLY.
NOW THIS IS AGAINST.
MY OWN TRIBE.
IT'S NOT THE BENEFIT OF MY TRIBE
TO SAY WHAT I'M SAYING.
IF YOU DISTRIBUTED EVENLY TO THE
RCF.
QUALIFICATIONS IF YOU WILL.
MY TRIBE AND POLITICALLY.
I'VE CONSTITUENTS AT HOME THAT I
GOT ANSWERED TO.
WANT TO KEEP THE MONEY.
WHICH MEANS THE TRIBES THAT HAVE
NO GAMING ZERO GAMING.
HAVE NO LEVERAGE NO COLLATERAL
TO BUILD ANYTHING OR NO LEVERAGE
EVEN QUALIFY FOR OTHER GRANTS
THAT ARE OUT THERE LIKE THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS
AVAILABLE TO US.
THEY WILL BUILD TO BUILD A
COMMUNITY.
SO AS A TROUBLE CHAIRMAN.
IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME TO.
BELIEVE THAT'S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF INDIAN COUNTRY IN
CALIFORNIA.
FOR COMEDY VALLEY TO.
GET A LITTLE EXTRA MONEY.
WHEN I HAVE TRIBES THAT ARE
SUFFERING NEXT DOOR TO ME.
STRUGGLING.
NO WATER.
NO WAY SYSTEMS.
NOT EVEN A JAM.
THE GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS ARE
FALLING APART.
FOR ME TO TAKE MONEY.
I PUT MYSELF FIRST.
I WOULD FEEL AS IF I WAS LETTING
MY COMMUNITY DOWN MY INDIAN
COMMUNITY DOWN. NEST NO
DISRESPECT MY COLLEAGUES HERE OR
ANYBODY ELSE OR ANY OTHER TRIBAL
LEADERS THAT ARE SPEAKING.
IT'S.
DIFFERENCE WE LIVE IN DIFFERENT
AREAS POSSIBLY.
AND WHEN YOU'RE THE CHAIRMAN OF
SIXTEEN TRIBES.
AND MORE THAN HALF OF TRIBES
HAVE.
VERY LITTLE.
IT'S VERY HARD.
TO SAY.
THE SMALL GAME TRIBE GIVE ME MY
SHARE BECAUSE IT'S EASIER.
TRIBES HAVE THRIVED WE HAVE
TRIED CUT ABOUT THIS THRIVED ON
THE GRANT PROCESS.
BECAUSE WHEN THERE'S MORE MONEY
AVAILABLE AND IT'S COMPETITIVE.
YOU COULD DO A BIGGER THINGS.
WE ALL KNOW THAT'S WHY WE'RE
CONSIDERING THE GRANT PROCESS.
IF YOU DISTRIBUTE EVENLY WHAT
CAN YOU BUILD.
WHAT CAN YOU HONESTLY DEVELOP?
NOTHING.
SO ONCE AGAIN WILL BE LEFT
PLEASE TRY TO HAVE ZERO WILL BE
LEFT STRUGGLING.
NOW SOME OF THE TRIBES THAT HAVE
ZERO WITH THE NOTES DISTRIBUTED
EVENLY BECAUSE.
THEY'RE AFRAID THAT THEY MIGHT
NOT HAVE THE.
STAFF TO QUALIFY FOR A GRANT.
THAT MIGHT BE A POSSIBILITY.
BUT IF WE NEVER OFFER A TRY FOUR
FIVE MILLION SIX MILLION TO
DEVELOP SOMETHING. THAT'S GOING
TO LAST A COMMUNITY FOR THIRTY
YEARS WHAT'S THE POINT OF THE
TRIBAL NATIONS GRAB FUN.
I AGREE THAT IT SHOULD NOT GO TO
PER CAPITA.
BUT ALSO. DISAGREE THAT IT
SHOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED EVENLY WE HAVE SO
MANY TRIED STRUGGLING THAT DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING.
AND ASK YOU.
TO.
POSSIBLY PUT POLITICS ASIDE.
AND ASK YOURSELVES IF YOU WERE.
A TRIBAL CHAIRMAN OF A
RESERVATION THAT HAD NOTHING.
WOULD YOU RATHER HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND.
MAYBE EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND.
OR WOULD YOU RATHER BILL THE
GYMNASIUM ERECT RECREATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUR PEOPLE.
WHICH YOU BROTHER BILL THIRTY
HOMES LIKE WE ARE FOR YOUR
PEOPLE.
WE CAN'T LET THE FEAR.
OF THOSE OF THE GRANT PROCESS
HOLD US BACK WE JUST CAN'T.
YOU HAVE TO WE TRIBES KNOW HOW
TO FIGHT FOR MONEY.
THE FIGHT HALF A MILLION IS A
FIGHT FOR NOTHING.
YOU CAN DO ANYTHING WITH IT.
SO I ASK YOU JUST TO TAKE UNDER
CONSIDERATION YOU TO PUT
YOURSELF IN MY SHOES DOT.
WHOEVER ALSO SHOES IF YOU WILL
TO BUT.
GOETHE TRIBES AN SEE AND ASK AND
AND LOOK AROUND TO SEE IF THEY
COULD BUILD ANYTHING WITH THAT.
MIDDLEMAN A MONEY.
SO THAT BEING SAID THAT'S JUST.
MY POSITION THE TRIBAL CHAIRMAN
FOR KIND OF IDENTICAL INDIANS
AND I HAD A JOB JUST AND MY AUNT
WOULD ALWAYS.
MY AUNT AFTER SHE WOULD GIVE ME
A LASSEN SHOULD END WITH THE
JOKE.
MR SO TO TALK THE NEXT DAY I
GUESS.
BUT THE.
I ALWAYS SAY YOU DO YOU KNOW HOW
CAN THE UNITED STATES WERE THE
FIRST PEOPLE ON THE MOON.
BECAUSE THEY HEARD INDIANS HAVE
LAND UP THERE.
THAT'S MY JOKE OF THE DAY.
I APPRECIATE YOU AND I REALLY DO
THINK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
TRIBES ARE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
TRAVEL AGENTS CRAP FUND. AND I
THINK WE SHOULD RESPECT WHAT THE
TRIBES THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THE
TRIAL MISSION GRANT FUND.
THERE THAT WHAT THEY WANT FOR
THEIR COMMUNITY AFTER CONTRIBUTE
TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU ALWAYS GOOD
TO HAVE SOME LEVIY.
THE IF IN HIS DISCUSSIONS WITH
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS AND.
YOUR THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO.
WHAT I THINK IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE? ON.
YOU PROVOKE SOME THOUGHT AS I.
IT'S IN HERE LISTENING TO
TESTIMONY ON.
IT WE WILL WE'VE RAISED ISSUES.
RELATED MY COMMENTS ON ON.
SOVEREIGNTY AND HOW DO WE AND WE
PRESERVE PROTECT AND RESPECT
THAT.
TO THE UTMOST DEGREE AND
CERTAINLY.
WE'VE MADE SOME AMENDMENTS TO
THE LEGISLATION.
WE'VE TRIED HAVE ADEQUATE.
PUBLIC REVIEW INCLUDING
OBVIOUSLY TODAY'S OPPORTUNE
DISCUSSES ISSUE IN SOME DETAIL
HERE FROM YOURSELVES AND.
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AND I
INTERESTED PARTIES.
I KNOW THERE WAS SEVERAL.
TRIBAL CONSULTATION
CONSULTATIONS HELD THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND I ASSUME SOME OF
THE FOLKS HERE PROBABLY
PARTICIPATED.
I IN THOSE IN REDWOOD VALLEY
AND.
.
PAULA ON TRINIDAD SACRAMENTO.
ON THE OPPORTUNITIES TO DISCUSS
THIS ISSUE BUT.
THE THE THOUGHT WHILE MY MIND IS
YOU KNOW WE WE RAISE THE ISSUE
OF EQUITY.
INTERESTING BECAUSE IS THE THE
CHAIRMAN.
.
A GREATER VALUE RAISES IN EQUITY
CAN BE VIEWED A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND AND IN SOME RESPECTS FROM
EQUAL DISTRIBUTION.
THAT PROHIBITS FOLKS FROM.
ENGAGING IN SOME WAYS ARE
DIRECTED HIS THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT.
A POINT THAT MAYBE YOU COULD
WALK US THROUGH I THINK ON.
WHEN YOU HIT ON THE ISSUE OF
INEQUITY HAD HOW DO YOU SEE A
CHAIRMAN.
.
AS RELATES COULD YOU ILLUSTRATE
SOME EXAMPLES. OF HOW THE SYSTEM
MIGHT GO AWRY IN YOUR MIND BASED
ON YOUR COMMENTS.
OFF-AGAIN. BUT TO BOTH. THE
GERMAN WOMAN ON THE RIGHT SIDE
THE TO HIT HER YEAH. DANGER
RATHER.
INEQUITY OF. WHOM IN DID IN
THOSE CONSULTATIONS.
.
PART OF THAT BUREAUCRATIC
PROCESS THAT WAS BEING
DISCUSSED.
JUST HAS NO THOSE POLITICS HERE
DOES POLITICS IN TRIBES IN AT
THE SACRAMENTO CONSULTATION
THERE WAS SOME OF THAT WAS
BROUGHT OUT YOU KNOW IT IS
MENTIONED.
HEY IF THAT TRIBES GET NO HAS A
GRANT APPLICATION AND THEY'RE
NOT GETTING THE FUNDS YOU KNOW
BECAUSE JUST IF THEY WERE TO SIT
ON THAT THAT THAT PANEL. SOLELY
WITHIN THEIR THERE'S THERE'S
THERE'S.
THERE'S KIND OF.
.
NO ANIMOSITY THERE'S THIS ISSUE
THE OTHER TRIBES RELATE TO
NEIGHBOR NEIGHBORING TRIBES THAT
THAT THEY HAVE THEIR AND SO IF
THERE WAS THAT PANELS TO BE
DEVELOPED. THEN.
NOTE THAT TRIBE MAY NOT IF
DEPEND ON WHO'S ON THE PANEL
WOULD BE ABLE TO BEGIN A TO GIVE
FUNDS.
THE INEQUITY THAT WE TALK ABOUT
AS FAR THE DISTRIBUTION.
WHERE I THINK IT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER ABOUT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS IS PROJECTED TO COME
INTO NEXT YEAR?
AND IN THOSE BECAUSE STATIONS
THEY SAID WELL MAYBE WOULD DO
LIKE A TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT HERE. LEFT IN TWO FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECTS THIS YOU
KNOW IN A GIVEN YEAR OVER HERE.
THE OTHER SEVENTY TWO TRIBES
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS YOU
KNOW THAT LAST TRIBE THAT'S
GONNA GET FUNDS TWENTY SOME
YEARS LATER YOU KNOW. DURING
THIS WHOLE TIME IF IT WAS FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. THEY
CAN GO GET USE THOSE FUNDS.
AND ACQUIRE SHOULD BE LANDING
YOU KNOW OVER THOSE OVER THOSE
YEARS AT TWENTY SEVEN YEARS BY
TIME THEY GOT RECEIVE FUNDS AND
HAD THAT INDEX. THAT'S ALWAYS
SAID IT'S DISTRIBUTE AN EQUAL
BASIS.
GIVE THOSE TRIBES.
AN OPPORTUNITY IN THE VERY FIRST
YEAR IF IT WAS TO BE PASSED ALL
SEVENTY TWO TRIBES TO GO OUT AND
SEEK TRADITIONAL LENDING AND ALL
TRIGGER TRIES BE EQUALLY
AFFECTED. AND USE THOSE FUNDS
HOW THEY FEEL.
BESS DRESSES THEIR KNEES ON THE
RESERVATION BECAUSE WHETHER IT'S
ROADS TO GYMNASIUM. WATER
SYSTEMS THEY CAN GO AND LEVERAGE
THOSE FUNDS IN THAT FIRST YEAR.
ALL SEVENTY TWO TRIES BUT IF YOU
HAVE TO WAIT TO TWENTY YEARS
LATER DOWN THE ROAD WHEN WHEN
YOU GET YOUR GRANT YOU KNOW
FINALLY. AND AND THEN LIKE
CHAIRMAN HUNTER SAID. YOU KNOW
THERE'S THERE'S THERE'S
ADMINISTRATION IS OUT THERE THAT
HAVE VERY VERY LIMITED STAFF OR
NONE AT ALL.
.
WE TALK ABOUT A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROCESS WE SEE THAT IN THE
FEDERAL. PROCESS RIGHT NOW WHERE
GRANT OF VERY COMPETITIVE YOU
KNOW AND EIGHT TRIBES HAVE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE THE FUNDS
ARE GOING TO BE A GOOD PURPOSE
AND THEY'RE GOING TO USE IT FOR
SUCCESSFUL.
APPLICATION.
KNOW HOW THE TRIBES GOING HELD
ONE TRIBE THAT HAS NO NO
MINISTRY OF STAFF GOING TO.
EUROPE AGAINST ANOTHER TRIBE HAS
A DECENT NO MINISTRY OF STAFF
THAT CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT THAT'S
GOING TO BE A SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS GOING CONTINUE TO
OPERATE.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE THE NOT
GOING TO BE EQUAL IN THERE FOR
THIS ONE PROBABLY WILL BE ON
PAPER A BETTER YOU KNOW AND THIS
ONE'S GOING TO BE RISKS YOU KNOW
A HIGHER RISK AND AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO WORK OUT FOR THEM
THEY'RE NOT GONNA GET. AWARDED
FUNDS.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'VE WE SEE.
THIS WHOLE PROCESS OF CREATING
ANOTHER AMINI B. I A IN
CALIFORNIA IS IT'S IT'S NOT SOME
THAT CALIFORNIA SHOULD WANT TO
DO YOU KNOW AND AND AND.
THE FUNDS THAT ARE BEING CREATED
IN THE AND AND THE TRIBES THERE.
ARE CONTRIBUTING TO IT THEY
DON'T WANT TO SEE ANOTHER
PATERNALISTIC YOU KNOW OR. BE
AYE A KINDA RULE FROM CALIFORNIA
THAT YOU WANTED TO HELP THOSE
ELIGIBLE TRIBES TO GET MORE FOR
MORE REFUNDS. RATHER THAN OURS
DO YOU HAVE AND AND SO THAT'S
WHY WE WERE PROPOSING SOME
THAT'S EQUAL BECOME A
DISTRIBUTED EQUALLY TO ALL THOSE
TRIBES IN IN IN THE FIRST YEAR.
ALL SEVENTY TRIBES TUNISIAN
CHARGE CAN BE COOLEY BENEFIT
FROM IT. IT DOES STRIKE ME I'M.
SO I THINK THERE'S COMPELLING
ARGUMENT ON BOTH SIDES AS I
LISTEN
TO THAT DISCUSSION AND IT
STRIKES ME THAT COMBINATION OF
THE HONESTY OF.
AND THE TNG HALF. ABOUT CREATE A
KIND OF A.
DUAL TRACK SYSTEM WHERE YOU DO
HAVE A BASELINE
FOR EVERY TRIBE AND YOU ALSO
HAVE A SEPARATE FUND THAT COULD
BE AWARDED IN PERHAPS A LARGER
CHUNKS.
FORCED THE FOR THE SPECIFIC.
TYPES PROJECTS IT CHAIRMAN
HUNTER RAISED.
IT DOES SEEM THAT THERE COULD BE
SOME BENEFIT THERE BUT IT IT IT
IT RAISES ANOTHER QUESTION IN MY
MIND THAT PREDATES MY SERVICE.
IN THE LEGISLATURE IN SOME
RESPECTS WITCHES.
BOTH OF THESE FUNDS WERE
NEGOTIATED COMPACTS.
RIGHT.
SO WHAT'S YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
WHY WE DIDN'T DEAL.
WITH.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO SPEND THE
MONEY AT THE TIME THAT WE
NEGOTIATED TO FIND IN THE
COMPACT BETWEEN THE STATE AND
THE TRIBE?
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY EACH TRIBE HAVE
TO SPEAK FOR ITSELF NAPA JUST
YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND. CERTAINLY
YOUR EXPERIENCES.
IN THOSE PROCESS
IN THAT PROCESS.
I AGREE I WOULD OBJECT THAT TO
ANY ANY OF THE CHAIRMAN WHO
WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND WE HEARD
AT AT ONE OF THE MEETINGS A SEA
KNIGHT WHO WAS.
THIS. WAS FORCED UPON THOSE.
TRIBES THAT HAD TO OF NEVER
COMING UP FOR COMBAT
NEGOTIATIONS IS SOMETHING THAT
THE STATE WANTED AND THEREFORE
HE WANTED THE COMPACT DISC WAS
SOME THAT WAS FORCED TO HAD TO
BE IN A COMPACT IF THEY WANT A
NEW COMPACT.
AND SO.
.
THEY HAD TO BASICALLY TAKE IT
YOU KNOW AND IF THEY WANTED A
COMPACT TO GET THROUGH
LEGISLATORS AND THAT'S THAT'S
BASICALLY WHAT WE HEARD.
CHRISTOPHER CROSSES.
THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT ARGUMENT
WOULD BE THAT'S A NEGOTIATION.
GRAVERT EVEN TAKE WHERE.
DUCK TO PARTIES.
DON'T END UP WITH EVERYTHING
THEY WANT IN THE IN THE COMPAQ
BUT IT'S JUST INTERESTING AYE
AYE THAT WE DIDN'T IDENTIFY
THAT.
AND PERHAPS IT WASN'T FORESEEN
TO BUY SOME OF THE TRACKS.
MORE I'D I'D LIKE TO RESPOND AS
WELL CAUSE I WAS THERE IN THE
BEGINNING WHEN WE START THE
NIGHT I'M COMPACTS.
AND WE DID HAVE A PROCESS IS
CALLED OUR STF.
AND AS EXACTLY WHAT WE MANAGED
TO DO IS GIVE THEM ONTO THE
TRIBES. THAT HAD LESS AGREE ON
FIFTY MACHINES NOW WE PAY INTO
THAT WE DON'T RECEIVE ANY MONEY
FROM.
BUT IS NOT OUR PLACE TO TELL
THEM WHAT TO DO WITH IT AND
NEVER DISRESPECTED A CHAIRMAN
HUNDRED THAT THE SOUNDS LIKE
HE'S DOING QUITE WELL.
WITHOUT THAT THE NEW TNG ACROSS
HAS BEEN INEFFECTIVE HE'S ONE
AFTER GRASSO AND I COMMEND HIM
FOR THAT.
HE IS DOING A REALLY GOOD JOB
THERE'S SOME TRIBES ARE JUST
THAT MAY NOT BE POSSIBLE.
BUT. ON THE OTHER HAND THEY MAY
BE ABLE TO LOOK TO THEM AS WELL
AND SO WILL LOOK THIS IS WHAT
THEY DID AND WE COULD DO THE
SAME THING.
SO.
IT IT IN AN ECONOMY. IF MEMORY
SERVES ME THE THE.
KID JEFF OBVIOUSLY WAS
ESTABLISHED.
LATER THAN THEY ARE CITY FM FOR
FOR THOSE ACCESS FUNDS AND MAYBE
MY QUESTIONS MORE PER THAT.
UPON THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THAT
FUND. WHY THE VARIOUS PARTIES
INCLUDING ADMINISTRATION AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DIDN'T
NEGOTIATE?
WELL THIS IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO.
ALLOCATE OR SPEND THESE FUNDS
WELL I GUESS I I DO.
RIGHT THERE WITH VIA.
DIDN'T ASK US EITHER SO.
OKAY PUBLIC.
IT'S KINDA GOES BACK TO THE
FACT WHICH PUBLIC HEARD FOR IN
THE CONSULTATIONS AS JOE DOING
AND MENTION.
IS TO DIVERSE.
THE DUBBED THE PERSPECTIVES OF
THE TRIBES YOU KNOW SOME WANTED
SOMEONE IT THIS WAY OTHERS ARE
OPPOSED TO IT.
WEARS A BECAUSE OF THE
BUREAUCRACY TO THE PROCESS
THAT'S GOING TO BE CREATED INTO
IT YOU KNOW THAT THE COMPETITIVE
PROCESS YOU KNOW AND THEN HAVING
A PANEL WHILE AND HAVE TO REVIEW
IN. AND SAY HEY YOU KNOW WHAT
TRIBE YOUR TRIED NEEDS ARE
GREATER THAN THIS TRIBES NEEDS
NO PUT EVERY TRIBE AS A SELF
GOVERNMENT HAS THE RIGHT TO
DETERMINE WHAT'S PRIORITIES OR
ITS OWN. AND IT SHOULD BE LEFT
UP TO A PANEL OR SOMEBODY ELSE
ANOTHER TRIBE.
TO TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY CAN HAVE THAT BECAUSE AND
SO THAT'S PROBABLY MOST LIKELY
THE REASON WHY A A FRAMEWORK
HASN'T BEEN.
DRAFTED IN PUTTING ANY COMPACT
AND STILL THE FRAMEWORK STILL
NOT EVEN IN AB EIGHTY AS IT IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. RICHEST
TRIBESMAN AGAIN THE SYSTEM FOR
PURPOSES OF DISCUSSION HERE.
TODAY THAT IT COULD HAVE BEEN A
FRAMER COULD HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED PRIOR TO ADOPTING. A
DOES COMPACTS THAT THE THAT THE
TNG AFTER DESERT AND BOTH
PARTIES WHO NEGOTIATED THE
COMPACT ON BOTH SIDES COULD
HAVE.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ESTABLISH THAT FRAMEWORK AND
HERE WE ARE DEALING WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TRIES
DAMAGE THAT FRAMEWORK THAT
WASN'T. OBVIOUSLY ESTABLISH SO
IT'S JUST AN INTERESTING A
DISCUSSION I'LL GO AHEAD AND
BRING IT BACK TO THE REST THE
COMMITTEE IF THERE'S.
SOME ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR.
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING THE OTHER LIKE TO THANK
ALL OF CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR TIME
AND.
AND YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY
AND I APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE ON
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC.
OKAY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE LAST PANEL.
AND ASK.
STACEY UNA BAXTER WELL AS
STEPHANIE.
ALICIA MATZAH TO APPROACH.
.
THIS.
BAXTER IS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GIMLI CONTROL COMMISSION. I WISH
NOT TO.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL IF
YOU GO AHEAD AND.
APPROACH AND PRESENT.
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
CORRECTION OUR MISS BAXTER'S NOT
ATTENDANCE AND WE HAVE A PINCH
HITTER SO GO AHEAD AND INTRODUCE
YOURSELF.
GOOD MORNING SERMON GRAY
INSTRUMENTS AUDIT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND A CARD DEPUTY
DIRECTOR LEGISLATION REGULATORY
AFFAIRS WITH THE CALIFORNIA GET
WHAT CONTROL COMMISSION. I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF STACEY
LYNN BAXTER AND WITH ME TODAY IS
RICHELLE RYAN. THE COMMISSION'S
TRIBAL FUNDS ADMINISTRATOR.
UNDER AB EIGHT EIGHTY THE
COMMISSION'S ROLE AS THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF THE FUND WOULD
BE SIMILAR TO THE COMMISSION'S
ROLE AS THE ADMINISTRATOR. OF
THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND
FOR THE PAST EIGHTEEN YEARS.
IN ADDITION THE COMMISSION WILL
PROVIDE ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR THE NEW GRANT
PROGRAM.
BASED ON THE DIRECTION OF THE
TRIBAL ADVISER IN THE PANEL AND
IN CONSULTATION WITH FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES.
THESE RESPONSIBILITIES WOULD
GENERALLY INCLUDE PROCESSING THE
GRANT APPLICATIONS PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE DISBURSING THE
GRANTS.
PROVIDING AN APPLICATION FORM
APPROVED BY THE PANEL AND
ASSISTING IN DEVELOPING THE
VARIOUS PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM.
THE COMMISSION WILL ALSO PROVIDE
APPLICATION FORMS TO ELIGIBLE
TRIBES AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO APPLICANTS ON THE
GRANT APPLICATION PROCESS.
IN ADDITION THE COMMISSION WILL
PREPARE AN ANNUAL REPORT ON THE
STATUS OF THE GRANTS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
UNDER EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY THE
COMMISSION WOULD NOT BE
PERMITTED TO COMPLETE A GRANT
APPLICATION ON BEHALF OF THE
TRIBE.
DEVELOP THE CRITERIA FOR THE
GRANTS OR EXERCISE IN THE
CONTROLLER DISCRETION. OVER THE
APPROVAL OR DISAPPROVAL OF THE
GRANT APPLICATIONS.
THE BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
RECENT COMPACTS THAT STATE OF
THE DIS THE COMMISSION SHALL NOT
EXERCISE CONTROL. OR DISCRETION
OVER THE USER DISBURSEMENT OF
TRIBAL NATION GRANDSON BUNNIES.
OVERALL THE COMMISSION'S
RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO THE
NEW TRIBAL NATION CRAP FUND
PROGRAMS WOULD INVOLVE
ADMINISTERING THE FUND. AND
PROVIDED ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
SERVICES TO HELP ESTABLISH AND
IMPLEMENT. THIS NEW PROGRAM.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ASSISTING
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ANY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
NECESSARY. AND WERE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MAX.
THE MORNING CHAIRMAN DODD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DEFINITION MAZU. AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE BUREAU OF GALA
CONTROL WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL HONEY SARAH THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY DISCUSS THE
BUREAU'S ROLE IN THE TRAVEL
NATION BRENNAN PROGRAM. AS
PROPOSED BY ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
EIGHTY.
SO WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND THE BUREAU CURRENTLY
HAS FORTY ONE POSITIONS IN ITS
BODY AND COME COMPAQ COMPLIANCE.
SECTION THE MAJORITY OF WHOM
ARE AUDITOR'S TO CONDUCT
COMPLAINTS REVIEWS PURSUANT TO
TROUBLE STATE GAMING COMPACTS.
AS WELL AS STATUTES AND
REGULATIONS PERTAINING TO
GAMBLING ESTABLISHMENTS OR CARD
ROOMS IN THE STATE.
FOR TRIBAL GAMING OUR STAFF
CONDUCTS AUDITS OF PAYMENTS TO
THE SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FUND.
THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND
AND OTHER REVENUE CONTRIBUTIONS
PROVIDE FOR THE COMPLEX.
I WHICH WILL ALSO INCLUDE TRAVEL
NATION RENDON.
THESE ARTISTS ARE CONDUCTED AT
LEAST EVERY TWO YEARS.
PERO STAFF ALSO CONDUCTS ANNUAL
REVIEWS TO ENSURE THE NON GAMING
AND THE MANY GAMING TRIBES ARE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THEIR
DISTRIBUTIONS FROM THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND.
AND REVIEWS MINIMUM TROUBLE
MIDDLEMAN TRAIL CONTROL
STANDARDS FOR CLASS THREE GAMING
AT LEAST EVERY TWO YEARS.
WE ALSO CONDUCT INSPECTIONS ARE
DESK REVIEWS FOR ELECTRONIC
GAMING DEVICES.
ABOUT FOUR TIMES A YEAR TO COME
FROM COMPLIANCE WITH
MANUFACTURER STANDARDS AND THE
TROUBLE.
GAME AGENCIES REGULATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY BUREAU STAFF AT OUR
TRIBAL LICENSING SECTION
ROUTINELY WORK TRAVEL GAME
AGENCIES.
ON LICENSING TYPE MATTERS FOR
TRIBAL KEY EMPLOYEES AND
VENDORS.
AND STAFF ARE COMPLIANCE AND
ENFORCEMENT SECTION CONDUCTS
ANNUAL COMPLIANCE COMPAQ
COMPLIANCE INSPECTIONS AND WORKS
WITH TROUBLED GAME AGENCIES ON
CRIMINAL MATTERS.
SO SINCE IT CALIFORNIA HAS
APPROVED TRIBAL GAMING WE HAVE
WORK TOWARD DEVELOPING POSITIVE
WORKING RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
TRIBAL GAMING AGENCIES ARE ALSO
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
PROVISIONS OF THE TRIBAL STATE
COMPACTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT EIGHTY AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED REQUIRES THINK
BUREAU TO CONDUCT AUDITS OF THE
USE OF THE GRANT FUNDS.
I FROM THE NET TREPIDATION GRANT
FUNDS.
THE PROCESS BROUGHT IN THE USE
OF THE GRANTS WILL BE DEVELOPED
BY THE TRAVEL ADVISOR AND THE
TREPIDATION GRANT PANEL. IN
CONSULTATION WITH FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA.
SO GIVEN THE BUREAU'S CURRENT
ROLE IN EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS IN TROUBLE
GAME AGENCIES WE BELIEVE. OUR
ROLE IN THE USE OF THE GRANT
FUND PROGRAM IS APPROPRIATE.
ONCE THE PANEL SELECTED THE
GRANT PROCESS ESTABLISHED IN THE
PROCESS FOR AIDID PIECE OF THE
GRANTS IS DEVELOPED BY THE
PANEL.
THE ROCHA BILL DETERMINE WHAT
TYPE OF ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
WILL NEED TO CARRY OUT OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES.
SO THANK YOU AND I AM OPEN TO
ANY QUESTIONS GREAT THANK YOU.
I HAVE A COUPLE OF FOR THE THAT
CAN WE KEEP TROLL COMMISSION
UNDER THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE THE.
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION WILL PROVIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE.
A SUPPORT.
I WOULD THE COMMISSION NEED AT
STAFF TO HEAR IT TO ADHERE TO
THIS MANDATE.
SO MADE THAT WE WOULD NEED ONE
POSITION AND FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM ART AT THIS POINT OUR
ESTIMATES.
IS THAT COSTS WOULD LIKELY BE
UNDER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR SO WE WOULD
NEED TO SUBMIT THE BCP.
FOR THOSE OF RESOURCES.
K..
AND THEN.
FOR THE GAMBLING CONTROL UNDER
THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE THAT
BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL WILL
CONDUCT AUDITS.
I TO ENSURE THE FUNDS ARE USED
IN A CONSISTENT MANNER WITH THE
APPLICATION OF THE AWARD.
HOUSES CONSISTENT WITH THE
CURRENT AUDITING REQUIREMENTS
THE BUREAU MAINTAINS. A RELATING
TO TRIBAL GAMING IS VERY
CONSISTENT THE BUREAU DOES ALL
OF THE KIND OF AUDITING AND
REVIEWS UNDER THE TROUBLE STATE
GAMING COMPACTS SO AGAIN SINCE
WE'D. HAVE WORKED A TRIED TO
ESTABLISH RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
TRIBES IN GAMING AGENCIES IT
SEEMS APPROPRIATE THAT WE WOULD
HANDLE THESE TYPE OF.
REVIEWS AS WELL.
GREAT THANK YOU I ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BROWN IN
THE.
MEMBERS.
A STATE NOT I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR TIME HERE THIS
MORNING IT GIVE US THIS VALUABLE
INFORMATION APPRECIATED.
NO I I'M NOT DONE YET.
OKAY.
.
WE A PUBLIC COMMENT. PERIOD NOW
ANYBODY FROM THE PUBLIC WHICH
SHE TO.
ADDRESS THE.
.
JOINT COMMITTEE.
IT'S OUR IT'S OKAY. GOOD MORNING
ATANY CAMERA TRIBAL ATTORNEY
FOR THE.
TOLERATING THE NATION WHICH IS
A LIMITED GAMING TRIBE.
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT MILES SOUTH
OF THE OREGON BORDER THEIR OF AN
ARTIST TF BENEFICIARY IN WOULD
BE THE BENEFICIARY OF THE TNG
OFF. WE SUPPORT.
THE EFFORTS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND THE TRIBES WHO HAVE
STEPPED UP AND ARE WILLING TO
FUND THE TNG OFF.
AND BELIEVE THAT.
WE ARE RELATIVELY CLOSE TO
HAVING AS CLOSE TO THE CONSENSUS
IS POSSIBLE MOVING FORWARD WITH
RESPECT TO WHAT AB EIGHT EIGHTY
LOOKS LIKE AND DUMP WE SUPPORT
THE EFFORTS.
UP I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO SEPARATE.
THE NEGOTIATION OF THE COMPACT
FROM THE IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE
COMPACTS OF THOSE TRIBES WHO'VE
AGREED TO PAY INTO THE END TNG
UP SELF THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN DODD AYE
CHAIRMAN RAYMOND CHUCKIE
HITCHCOCK I'M.
CHAIRMAN WHAT RANCHERIA HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
I I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
EIGHTY.
I KNOW THERE'S SOME LANGUAGE
THAT NEEDS TO BE WORKED OUT. BUT
WE ARE REVENUE SHARING TRUST
FUND TRIBE HERE WE HAVE ALMOST
EIGHT HUNDRED MEMBERS AND WHERE
ARE FORTUNATE TO GET THE ONE
POINT ONE MILLION.
I AS JUST RECENTLY LAST YEAR WE.
ENTERED INTO A COMPACT THAT HAS
A TRIBAL NATIONS GRANT FUND AND
WE WERE GIVEN MEANINGFUL
CONCESSIONS IS PART OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS WHICH WE. ARE WE
REFER RESPECTFULLY.
AGREED TO.
I THE TRIBAL NATIONS GRANT FUND
WITH THE EXCESS MONEY WOULD GIVE
TRIBES AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAP
INTO OTHER RESOURCES IN GRANTS
TO HELP THEIR MEMBERS IN THEIR
TRIBES.
I SEE THAT THE LANGUAGE HAS.
COMPETITIVE GRANTS IN IT AND
THAT'S KIND OF THE CONTENTION.
YEAH A HUNDRED NINE TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA SO YOU GET A HUNDRED
NINE DIFFERENT VIEWS ON THIS BUT
I THINK THERE'S A BALANCE THAT
CAN BE STRUCK BETWEEN THIS OF.
POTENTIAL COMPETITIVE GRANTS
THAT IF THERE'S THIRTY MILLION
IN A POT FIFTEEN MILLION OF ITS
FOR COMPETITIVE GRANTS IN THE
OTHER FIFTEEN COULD BE.
SPLIT EQUALLY AMONG TRIBES
THAT ARE ARE STF.
AND THOSE EQUALLY AMOUNTS COULD
BE BASED OFF OF HOW MANY
MEMBERS.
BECAUSE OUR TRIBE HAS EIGHT
HUNDRED MEMBERS CLOSELY AND WE A
ONE POINT ONE MILLION AND HAVE
ANOTHER TRY THAT MAY ONLY HAVE
THIRTY MEMBERS AND THEY GET ONE
POINT ONE MILLION. SO THERE'S
LITTLE DIVERSITY THERE WHAT YOU
CAN DO WITH EIGHT HUNDRED
MEMBERS AND ONE POINT ONE
MILLION AND TWENTY MEMBERS. TO
PROVIDE SERVICES
WE CURRENTLY USE OUR TF FUNDS
TO HELP ELDER SERVICES AYE WE
GIVE SCHOLARSHIPS TO OUR OUR
STUDENTS TO GO TO COLLEGE AND
THINGS THAT NATURE. I JUST THINK
THERE'S LANGUAGE THAT CAN BE
WORKED AS LONG AS IT'S.
AGREE WITH THE TRIBE THE TRIBAL
ADVISER POSITION IS SOMETHING
THAT'S IMPORTANT AS A PERMANENT
POSITION WITH THE GOVERNOR.
SOMEBODY THAT'S FROM A FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBE TO BE THAT
LIAISON BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND THE TRIBES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY IS ALREADY
SEE SOMETHING THAT ALL TRIBES
ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT I THINK
AT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN
MISTER JONAS. I WORK TO TRY TO
YOU KNOW LEVY EIGHT SOME OF THAT
LANGUAGE AS WELL.
.
I I I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY HERE WITH
THE GOVERNOR LEAVING THIS YEAR
SEEKING OUT TO FIND FIND THE
STRIKE THE BALANCE. AND MAKE
THIS HAPPEN THIS YEAR DOING THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION AND DON'T
LET THIS SLIP AWAY BECAUSE THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL TRIBES
TO BE ABLE TO. I REAP THE
BENEFITS OF THIS IT'S JUST.
FINDING THAT BALANCE THAT
EVERYBODY CAN AGREE ON THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SUSAN JOHNSON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA NATION'S
INDIAN GAMING ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT THIRTY FIVE TRIBES
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
FROM TRIBES OF BOTH PAY INTO THE
TNG F.. AND THOSE.
THAT WILL BE RECIPIENTS OF THE
T. NGF AND AS YOU'VE SEEN TODAY.
THERE'S DISAGREEMENT AMONG HOW
THAT'S DONE THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THE T. NGF THERE'S OPPOSITION
MOST OF THE OPPOSITION COMES
FROM THE COMPACT IN PROCESS SO
TRYING TO TAKE THE CONTRACTING
PROCESS OUT. BUT THAT BE BETWEEN
THE TRIBE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE LOOKING AT EIGHT EIGHTY
WE AGREE THAT THIS MONEY SHOULD
I BE DISTRIBUTED HOW THAT MONEY
IS GOING TO BE DISTRIBUTED.
IS THE LOOK BUT IS THE RUB AND
SO WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR
MEMBERS WE APPRECIATE THIS
HEARING I THINK THIS.
BEGINS THAT DISCUSSION MORE
WITH YOU DIRECTLY WITH THE
TRIBES.
AND WE'RE GONNA DO OUR BEST TO.
HELP MOVE THIS FORWARD IN SOME
WAY THAT WORKS FOR AND ALL OF
THE TRIBES BUT WE WANT TO. SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING AND A STARTING THAT
DISCUSSION.
ANYBODY ELSE FROM THE PUBLIC
WHICH SEEM TO ADDRESS A JOINT
COMMITTEE.
WELL THAT CONCLUDES THE.
.
A JOINT HEARING THIS MORNING I
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS.
.
WHO WERE IN ATTENDANCE TODAY I
WANT TO THANK STAFF AND ALSO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
INTERESTED PARTIES?
FOR BEING HERE TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WHAT